Oh,
how good was big man
with him.
It's,
it was,
it was in the hospital with Tupac and then it went dead with the biggest debt
and then it became hip hop and everybody was going out for dollars and they made
it a lot and it made a lot of shitty music except for m and m and JC,
maybe not Ralphie may dropping wrap knowledge.
Ralphie May's in the Harris,
ladies and gentlemen,
our guest,
he's very disgruntled at the world of rap music and I know it's your concern as
well,
but this show and all shows a sponsor by the fleshlight Ralphy you ever felt a
fleshlight,
sir?
No,
no one is fucked this it.
A lot of people fingered it.
Well,
you know Nate rubber tips.
This flashlight is not a virgin,
but it's like a slutty junior high school girl.
Been fingered a lot,
isn't it?
An amazing feels great,
right?
Pretty creepy dude.
It,
it's way better than just regular jerking off.
And the best thing is if you have somebody else hold it and fuck you,
it's even more detached from your own body.
So it feels like you are actually having sex.
Have you done that,
Joe?
Have you had somebody else hold the flashlight for you and someone else there?
I'm going to fuck them.
Let's,
it's a boy.
Why is he holding it?
Well,
it's like the hand job.
It's the newest hand job I me get the girl is going to give you a hand job
nowadays.
Hey,
give me a hand job with a flashlight and state.
It's way better than a regular hand job.
Yeah.
Oh dude,
try it.
Have
a girl's hand is always going to feel better.
It's a shitty person touching you,
Ralph.
He says no,
but by its fruit,
can you come with glass gets I'll fuck everything was fast.
No Man.
What's wrong with you?
Come up.
A girl's giving given your hand job.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
I know.
Even though you're doing,
I can't forget.
You need some more stimulation,
Percy.
Okay.
I've never even come from a blowjob.
What I'm saying?
My Ralphy same way.
I do not like blow dry.
I mean it's the way girls are blowing youtube.
No,
I'm married.
I'm sealed man.
I like all my shit.
I just stay on the straight and narrow,
but that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is even her,
even even,
oh yeah,
man.
Yeah,
my wife.
Horrible blow job.
Let's be honest.
A you,
it comes with the territory.
They Nag would then go with money and they get great kid,
Jewish girls.
That was the reputation that they'd like to give blow jobs,
not this one.
Yeah,
that's what I always thought.
That stereotype.
I never heard of that ever.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
Finally said that.
Good for the Jews.
I don't mind the candle just for that one.
[inaudible] that we've had it for a seriously nine years.
10 years.
I found it in the garage.
I went and got a candle.
All right,
and the kids just going to sing happy birthday because this dollar note,
I don't know any Hanukkah songs.
I don't really think about it.
My wife's met a good Jew.
Alright,
but I'm lighting a candle just for that one.
Just letting my daughter,
no,
she's got a good rep.
I always heard that j Jewish women are just the craziest and bed,
anything.
They're just this crazy sex machine in they shoes and she did fuck me.
So that makes me fucking crazy.
Yeah,
just I need to try it once.
Never tried a black girl.
No,
I'm,
I'm as a lot of my get the Nero there was just like it.
Bingo.
You might get Deniro Dsi.
You don't even into white chicks anymore.
You might start talking like there's,
I was at BW three
Gangsta it out.
Come on baby.
No,
there's this black chick at BW three s last night.
Then the next move was so beautiful.
Those bungling you what happened?
You don't even have to tell him that man white dude.
He looks black chicks,
New Sun son.
Embrace your inner love of black chicks.
That's the next move for you,
sir.
That's some hard ass black chick that fucks the shit out of you and tells all
your ex girlfriend's a step like little camp.
So if you have any issues with ex-girlfriend's to get their scan of that black
bitch,
that girl.
All right,
so big long nails.
The girl at the BW.
Three s in Burbank,
the bartender.
You are cute.
Whoa.
What are you a fucking five year old?
Go tell her in person,
but the tree,
I don't even use that word anymore.
I want to take you to the olive garden.
Ah,
Jesus Christ as their sponsor.
Brian,
sorry you.
How dare you.
How dare you come off like a 12 year old on the show.
I think you have by life.
Who Do you like mean?
Check one.
Yes,
please aim me.
You smell.
It really could just give out your aim.
I know you got one.
Here's your fucking Weirdo.
Here's my Facebook.
Ralphie may rocks.
It's so old school.
He doesn't even have a Twitter.
How do you like them apples?
That's almost not exist.
You text,
you text a lot.
Yeah,
and I'm sick.
It's just takes out to,
you got to get on the Twitter.
The person who pull out their Ralphie did want to talk to you,
man.
They're happy.
You're on the show today.
And they go to my shows and they say,
what's up?
Oh yeah,
there is a lot of people actually they,
um,
today I got a lot of phone messages of people saying,
cause like a lot of comics watches a podcast.
Yeah.
Cool.
I gotta move this out of my face.
This is freaking me out.
Sorry.
Go back a little bit.
That's right when you're shooting a gun.
And
I'm like trying to move around it while I'm looking at you on the podcast.
Dan Microphones.
Dan Rather was in his mouth so,
well,
yeah,
you got to use the Twitter mountains.
It's very important.
There's a lot of people that want to talk to you.
And not only is it good for promotion,
it's great for writing comedy,
choke beginning talking shit about things.
It's fun.
Yep.
But I'm nervous.
I'm nervous that
I would become too exposed.
What are you talking about?
Like,
you know,
uh,
I have become too exposed as,
as like,
you know,
a go to guy for free.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
am I going to,
I write hours and hours of material,
you know,
right now I have three and a half,
maybe four hours in rotation that I do separately.
Awesome.
And it's all different stuff and it's all the same basic thing.
And so I find myself just writing the same thing over and over again in a
different form and a different subject.
You know what I mean?
The same formula and I'm nervous that I would get polluted by other comedians
and I just don't want to open myself up polluted by other comedians.
You don't have to follow in it but he don't want to follow and you can some
people like I don't think Louis C K for the longest time didn't follow anybody.
Zero followers really.
She was a fucking only applied heads,
never replied to anybody's zero followers.
You try to make her reply,
she will not do it.
And she almost seems like she's like an app like typing,
you know it just automatically puts something sexy and mixed with something.
You might be absolutely right about that because I've read some of those that
she writes cause they like been featured on websites and shit and they're crazy.
They're all like,
you know,
I'm going to go down to this high school and try to get five dudes to shoot
loads in me.
I'm at the airport right now.
I have dried calm and my face,
but if you watch your videos you're like,
well she's obviously for real.
She is throwing down Bri Olsen.
She's funny,
very popular,
Young Porno Star with a wonderful personality and I have excellent
sense of humor.
She Brody Stevens,
he gets set,
take meat.
She can take meat.
It's weird,
man.
We've talked about this on the podcast before,
but was she one of the girls and like the biggest slut contest for how to start?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Yeah,
I think you're probably right.
She was talking about as she'd fuck a retard and fun.
I love it.
I can tell her that's all those girls that do those gang bangers.
Man.
That's a different species.
Dang man.
That's another human bro.
That's another kind of speaking to another human.
I saw Jay London picking up trash on.
Laurel Canyon creep me out.
He was picking up trash for somebody and see working.
My man,
he had a,
he had an orange jacket,
orange vest on him,
like say something and he got arrested.
I don't know.
That's not what usually that is.
You get arrested sometimes.
I think so man.
I think so.
And it was crazy.
It wasn't last comic standing.
No,
no,
no.
I'm like the next one he was on the next one.
You know Jay and I were on the,
for the first TV show I ever did in 19 I think it was 92 it was a lot of
spotlight cafe,
this weird show in New York and Jay was on it with me and that I always thought
like,
wow,
this guy is so quirky and interesting.
Like this guy,
he's going to be a famous comedian.
And then he got on last comic standing and I'm like,
wow,
here it goes.
Maybe people and you know,
people started recognizing him at the comedy store and then nothing happened.
I'll stop.
It just went away.
Have done the best of anybody of capitalizing on that last comic standing proud
and running with it.
You ran with that shit dude.
There's a lot of guys who like John Heffron ran with it pretty well too,
but I think you ran with it even better.
You were prolific,
highlighted you more than anyone and that you're the only person on that show
that when I watched it,
when it was originally on,
I saw you blow up audiences.
I mean you just destroyed on that show.
You like a regular last comic standing person,
you are tearing up rooms to
me and told me and show me the minutes from the MVC meeting.
Okay.
Like he probably shouldn't have.
And he told me that they were nervous about having someone my size on NBC a lot,
especially in prime time.
Worried about what you're dying or something?
No,
just the image it would put out there.
They were embarrassed by my sides and I feel like it's crushing.
Um,
but I,
I use it as motivation and he goes,
the only way they're not going to uh,
uh,
get you off of this is if you get a standing ovation every show.
That's the only way they can deny it.
It's because we can't retake that tape and that,
and he goes,
we won't be able to,
if you every joke kills,
we won't be able to show you bombing.
What is it?
He goes,
if,
if every
joke of your as kills,
right,
then we won't be able to show that you bombed to tell you that you lost it.
You show the audience that you lost me.
No,
you have to get a standing ovation every show and every joke be your hardest
that you've ever delivered it.
That's the only way these people aren't going to get you outta here.
Wow.
So they were plotting to get you out from the beginning because of the way you,
your body is.
Wow.
But yet now one of the shows on TV,
on NBC as big as loser.
Well for those folks who don't listen on iTunes and you don't,
you're not familiar with Ralphie is how,
how big are you?
Ralphy uh,
right now I'm a four 18 418 pounds.
Well that's dumb.
Down from over 700.
Wow.
I know.
I've lost a whole fuck a fat guy and I'm still fat.
Not that much of an accomplishment.
Hundred at one point.
Yeah.
We'll get you a member of the back of the company was store.
Do you want her to take me to the Strip joint?
Just to see any grill getting there?
My Dick and,
and you wouldn't throw me in your accurate and it,
there was no fucking getting in.
NSX was not having,
it was sick.
It was a sick card,
but there was no way I was getting in there.
And I'm like,
I love you Joe Rogan.
I love your heart.
You have tried to care for her.
But what cars are going,
Huh?
Not Anymore.
They're all pretty much,
you know what I mean?
I got into ridiculous $600,000 Mercedes Benz,
so to see what it thousand dollars for a Mercedes
convertible and it's like 700 horse power and it's a,
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
It's like AMG some shit.
It was in Beverly Hills,
Mercedes Mailton.
My friend as comedian is the sales manager there.
I don't think it's not Ron Robertson.
I think it's three 50 no,
it's six 49 200 inch plasma TVs in the trunk.
I'm wrong.
Kind of another model.
Yeah,
it's just bad at,
but totally the most uncomfortable car I've ever been.
Yeah.
But my beamer,
I got six 50 I
convertible and it's fun.
I don't have no problem.
No Ralph,
he says,
no problem.
I'm all about comfort.
Ever since I got my new car,
it's like the biggest mom car ever.
You know,
it's a Ford Edge,
but I,
you know,
it's so comfortable.
It's fucking comfortable and it's so techie like I will,
you know everything.
I love it.
I'm telling you what American cars I fucking making a comeback.
See time man
and your lower back.
Do you don't feel it.
The fatigue.
They have a little drive.
Shelby Shelby gt 500 ooh convertible.
Yeah,
cause you're good.
So it's,
this was the dumbest one ever though.
All you have to do is anytime you want stomp on the gas and the cargo sideways,
sideways,
right?
Just start spinning wheels.
And it's a tiny car.
It's lightweight.
It's got to live rear axle.
So it handles like shit.
But it's fun.
You stomp on the gas.
Just leaves rubber dude.
It's a pure American experience.
A car like that.
Like,
yeah,
it's not sophisticated.
It's not the best way to get around.
Not the best handling,
but God damn,
that shit is fun.
It's fun.
Yeah.
You stomped on the gas.
It's 550 horsepower and it's supercharged and so it's,
you hear the supercharger whine
you the V eight and the will the wine in here.
Wow.
That's
getting it done.
Oh,
this,
it's like a different thing.
It's not just driving,
it's not just getting in your fucking,
your Yukon and you know,
going to the supermarket.
There's something extra fun about it.
Very irresponsible.
It is,
man.
It's like James Bond makes him dangerous.
Shit can have it anytime.
It's just a fun,
it's just fun.
Even if you're not speeding,
it's fun.
The Lurch of it.
Just the rumble,
the you feel the power in those cars.
I sit here,
my turn single when I go around this neighborhood age is awesome.
It's like,
but those are good cars.
Fuck it,
man.
Yeah.
You're already behind.
You're making yourself over.
You're turning in Armenia mean you've got your moving to Glendale,
you got the beard,
you're 10 and then ever is that the next Move Glendale?
I'm think.
Well,
my beard says yes.
I want to go to the beach.
I've just,
I can't take it anymore.
I need to go to the beach and not as something that's calling you about rarely.
Yeah.
I just,
the vibe,
the vibe and the beach.
He's full man and everyone knows everyone.
It's,
I totally agree.
Yeah.
I think there's some homeless and it's steaky.
Oh yeah,
Santa Monica.
But you could play it el Ray.
You got down to her most sites wider than holding traffic,
getting there.
White people.
What is way white people and that no homeless people,
the homeless,
homeless person that's there has a people as a credit card with all saying that,
fuck white people.
Yeah.
Right.
How did their bullshit,
I am tired of the bullshit,
man.
This shit we fucking,
Arizona is bullshit.
I mean,
they give white people bad name.
Yeah.
The,
the whole,
yeah.
You know,
the real problem is they don't need to kill these fucking crazy assholes in
Mexico.
They're just gunning people down for cocaine.
Dude,
28,000 since 2005 they got a bad problem down there and it's,
it's totally unattractive.
I wreck us laws is 5,000 let's put it in perspective.
How many people that really is.
Yeah.
It's pretty crazy.
And that's the ones they know about.
Yeah.
I thought the heads of the desert.
Okay.
There's lots of that shit.
There's a lot of that shit going on.
ICICLES.
Dangerous.
I like.
Yeah.
It's the border towns especially,
I mean,
it's really crazy right now in most Americans are blissfully unaware.
Oh,
nuts.
It is down there.
They have no idea,
man.
Listen man,
if you go to Laredo,
Texas,
man,
fuck that.
You were out the door.
It used to be nice.
She used to go across the border.
You know you go down like I have a weekend of San Antonio and then Sunday night
go down there,
they'll get a great deal.
Like a,
a great hotel.
The holiday in there,
it was safe.
It was nice.
You go to a Nouveau Laredo,
cross the bridge,
bring back glass and plates and stuff like that and it was awesome living.
Ron Wyden live there?
Yeah.
Okay,
awesome.
It was just a great river valley.
Okay.
Town smelled like cigars everywhere.
It was smelling like great thanks guys.
No,
you get cubits.
The guy.
What else?
How about candy?
Anything in that?
Ron White smells like
guys.
He told me one time to bring a weed and I'm like,
you're the only guy ever to ask anyone to bring weed to Mexico.
What are you talking about?
Go talk to somebody.
Bring Weed to Mexico.
Yeah,
that sounds,
we wanted me to come.
The whole idea we to or back from Mexico sounds like a terrible idea,
man.
Taking wheat into gloms a bad idea.
Yeah.
Let me hear that story.
Sun.
This is,
this is a Ralphie may classic that's making the rounds and uh,
I'm,
I don't know all the details so I want to hear the whole deal.
Cause you got,
you got arrested somewhere.
Yeah,
I got,
I got stopped in Guam,
uh,
for weed.
I didn't know I had it on me.
All right.
And I took out of my bag,
three and a half ounces of weed.
Uh,
a full ounce of Keith and about 20 grams a hash.
God.
Damn.
That's what I took out of my back.
He took it out before he went to the airport.
He took all that stuff.
You may wants to party.
Yeah,
I like to get down.
I like variety.
You know,
I've,
I mean,
you look at me,
I've got no fucking control.
Okay.
Have Anything Joe Rogan look at me except Mez.
Yeah,
that maybe the control over your loads.
Look,
you got really good control.
The one thing I've got for me,
um,
but I'm a mess.
I mean,
I've got no sense.
Plus,
I get tons of heavy handshakes.
I mean,
and those,
these guys aren't Phelan and sent me the throw in an eighth.
Right?
So quarter,
you know,
when I tell them how it was stone and saw,
uh,
the,
the miracle on the Hudson happened,
I would just afterwards,
okay,
we were down there at Chelsea piers and people running.
That's what a fucking cop on a horse.
I am stoned out of my fucking mind.
I in my Hammock,
I sound stone like a biblical whore and I,
I'm fucking wasted.
And I'm like walking seriously.
I'm fucked up.
Like if it wasn't like 29 degrees and sunny,
I would have passed the fuck out.
I was that high.
Wow.
I had a big thing of Hash and I put that in the middle.
I made a Joey Diaz Cuban sandwich with a Oh Geez.
On the sativa on the top and then a big fucking chunk,
a hash over a gram and um,
uh,
an Oji finish.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's,
and I was the one of the most fucked up I've ever been.
And I'm walking and in so much I'm seeing people run from the end of the period
to the edge overhead helicopters.
I see a cop on a fucking horse and I'm like,
wow.
And he was within 20 feet of me.
And I'm like,
where the fuck are you going to Sundance?
It made,
it won't appear.
Okay.
You're on a fucking peer.
There's people all around,
you know,
my kid has been my wife's arms,
you know the fuck.
Wow.
Okay.
And,
and we went down there to go see that.
I'm a kind of,
uh,
aviation buck and the air.
Was it the blackboard spy plane?
The AI 71?
I think it was.
Um,
it's the fastest plane.
We have a bill,
you know,
that we told anyone about and it's fucking cool as shit because on its last
voyage it flew from New York to la or la to New York and like 38 minutes,
something insane.
Speed La to New York and 38 next time traveling Nigga.
That's,
that's how real can look it up.
Ar 17 ar some her 17 blackbird [inaudible] 71 [inaudible] 71.
No,
no,
no.
It was a 71.
It's a blackboard spy plane.
So do wow.
Check that fucker out.
And it was the,
was the last declassified flight of,
it was the only one that they showed the speed and,
and we,
we retired this motherfucker.
Why would you ever retire this thing?
Can you put it up there,
Bruh?
I Dunno how to do all that shit.
You're amazing.
I got an IPAD APP.
It was a friend.
This thing goes 2000 miles an hour.
So then it couldn't have gone.
It could've been,
yeah.
This is what they did in one hour and 54 minutes.
They went from New York to London.
That's the six hour flight.
They did it an hour and 54.
They went from the last one,
the flu,
the one that's at the,
uh,
um,
the battleship there.
Was it the intrepid.
Okay.
And Damage Chelsea Piers.
All right.
That's what I wanted to go see.
I wanted to be high and be close to that fucking jet.
Right.
I mean that's,
that's almost Tom Chaplain.
I mean,
do you understand?
Dude,
that's fucking mom blowing.
Oh,
still hours.
You can leave London.
You can have tea in London and lunch and dinner in New York City and not miss a
fucking big bro.
That's amazing.
There's transfer shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's amazing.
You know what's really crazy is they used to have that,
um,
that Concord that you could fly to Europe.
Yes.
No solid plane.
Cool.
Shit.
I used to go super high.
It was like way higher than a regular plane.
So it literally,
like you were on the border of fucking space,
inner a space,
going to the speed of sound.
Fucking a man.
Stop and think about a plane that goes as fast as fucking sound and you're
sitting in that bitch.
Just fuck it.
Yeah.
You don't feel the g force because they just,
they don't make any sudden moves and they just totally amp it up saying say it
and just go straight up and straight down.
So cool sound man.
The speed of sound in a fucking plane,
but it kept killing too many rich folks.
Boy.
Right.
People,
the attitude they fucked up.
But I think the last one,
I think it was a really dumb fuck up too.
It's like somebody hit a tire there,
was left on the track,
the Concorde hit it and fucking caused a gigantic explosion.
Never let it died.
When
those people are dying and they're dying.
And these are people that are paying like $10,000 a ticket type t more than that
last rites glass.
Yeah.
Right.
So $10,000 she was like regular,
right?
Yeah.
For like economy.
Economy is $10,000 and it's just to save a few hours of your time.
That's really what it is.
It's just ended because cool.
Novelty effect of it.
I remember I was watching some talk show as a kid and there was an actor who
said the coolest thing he'd ever done it was take that Concord.
Yeah.
And then stand on his seat.
So he was the highest person in the world.
Whoa.
That's hilarious.
And he's right.
He's like,
he stood at his feet and he was,
well,
the a live person.
No.
There was no astronauts into orbit at that time.
Right.
There was nothing going on.
Planes still freaked me out.
Just the idea that you're in this metal tube,
it's 30,000 feet in the air and you're just sitting there and you're just
chillin and looking at your iPad and your,
Your Adam's are holding us up is visible as connected from the ground.
That's where I want to be.
Want to be on the ground where it's safe.
You have no fucking feed up there.
Ooh.
I get a lot of anxiety when a fly.
What do you think they have that we don't know about?
One of the things you said about the SR 71 you said it was the fastest plane
that day that we have that we know about that we haven't told.
What about,
yeah.
Do you think,
well,
it would just seem to reason.
I mean when,
yeah,
logic that if you made that much progress in 30 years,
that that,
you know,
exponentially if you take the same progress,
like in cell phones in the last 20 years from a briefcase with a cord and a
headset,
and then,
and then the move down was the brick.
Okay.
That was the,
after that.
Okay.
That same technology,
now they're microscopic and they can,
you ain't no cut tons of data.
I mean,
you just take that same stream of technology and apply that to that another
sector where we're spending billions and billions and billions of dollars on
projects that we don't even know about.
Fuck yeah.
There's gotta be something faster.
I want to know about,
I want to know about harp up in Alaska.
um,
the f f 23 that,
uh,
supposedly can hover and,
um,
and it's a scram jet.
Okay.
I want to know about that.
Uh,
that it could fly at 120,000 feet.
Okay.
And I can go from,
uh,
it can go from,
last and well outside of Las ad,
uh,
Las Vegas supposedly.
Eh,
fuck,
it takes off.
And then it refuels at about 90,000 feet.
No,
45,000 feet on its way to 90,000 feet.
And then it hits the APP stores meets those clean and refueled in the air.
How dope is that?
They refuel in the fucking sky.
Yeah,
and from the fuck are they doing that man?
I don't know.
And then it's the cleanest burning and it's a fastest and people can go from a
last,
it'll be all over the Pacific where there's no body.
They fucking,
they refuel and then they hit that scram jet and they got 120 140,000 feet,
like the outer atmosphere shit.
And then bounce back off of it.
And,
and what?
You don't understand what you,
if you go straight up and you continue in a straight line,
the earth is moving in like 17,000 miles per hour.
So that's adding to your speed.
Fuck a trippy.
When you add altitude and then gravity on top of that compounding.
So you're falling much faster,
you know,
thousands,
it could go up to theoretically 3000 miles per hour,
4,000 miles per hour.
Fucking amazing.
Do you guys remember how cool it was in the 80s and then about that blackbird?
Remember the blackbird?
It was like the f 15 or whatever.
Where's it was like a wrap your head around that kind of fucking speed.
No Man,
it's ton traveling,
man.
That's the closest we're ever going to get.
I wonder if they have some shit that's not released.
It's even faster than what we know about like three or four times the speed of
sound.
So I'm really,
what about,
what about that decommissioned a supercollider in Waxahachie,
Texas that's still a federal off limits facility that uh,
that say we did say we created the God particle like they did in Switzerland and
which is a controlled microscopic,
a subatomic black hole.
And then the energy explodes off that we collect that theoretically that in a
bottle,
any matter we could,
we could stream banging each other in,
control that black hole that we could,
uh,
in the left of water get boomed from there.
We could fuel all of North America's energy sources in an amazing,
it's fucking unbelievable.
They've the super colliding shit.
Right?
That's right.
I mean,
it's fascinating,
but I mean,
I think those,
the idea behind the making the little black holes that they don't have enough
gravity to stay alive.
Yeah.
They die out.
Well,
that's the,
well,
the scary version thinking that someone's doing something with the one that they
have in Texas.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
That it's not Mindy commissioned,
you know,
and that it's being used.
I mean,
the fucking government uses everything else from the 50s they're going to,
they're going to drop,
you know,
800 billion in a fucking hole in the Waxahatchee and then just say,
fuck it.
We're out.
Well,
I don't believe that they're doing sunding thing though.
You know,
a lot of times there's just not enough money to run shit if they don't think
they're going to get a direct result off of the experiments.
Like,
what is,
what's going to be profitable out of these experiences?
What military applications is going to come from this experiment?
And if there's none,
it's real hard to justify when the economy goes to shit.
They clothes things like that down all the time.
But I mean is it really close though?
So we're still spending,
they're doing something,
some crazy shit man.
The whole area 51 is the most fascinating thing to me that they had a whole area
that they denied even existed until I think it was like in the late nineties
they tried to expand the boundaries of it and they will,
they had to claim more land for to be restricted.
And then they had admitted it exists in the place.
But for the longest time there was just people waiting with guns.
But too many dudes found like this spot in the hills where you could watch them
experiment with their Aircrafts and too many guys who worked there who either
got fired or went crazy and like Bob Lazard,
no,
he is.
He's the guy that,
you know,
he's,
he's been ridiculed.
A lot of people say that he's full of shit and he lied about his education
background.
I don't know what's the case or what's not the case.
But his story that on a resume to get a job.
Yeah,
but you need to say I had degrees in places,
they said he'd never enrolled and there's like old yearbooks from those times
and he does.
He's not in the yearbook.
So it seems like at the very least he's made some things up.
So you know,
you gotta you gotta look at it and say,
well he probably made it all up.
But the point is he would take his friends to watch these things flying in the
air and he said he worked there and they arrested them there and once they
arrested him there,
there's like a,
you know,
it was his big story and he came out and said there was flying saucers there and
that he had worked on him and tried to back engine the emirate fucking
fascinating shit.
But the point,
the number one point is there really is a place where they're doing secret shit
and they didn't want people to know about it and they had to tell them more than
one of these.
Once they had satellites and satellite started flying over and taking
photographs of it.
And people could see like the whole facility and groom Lake and you could see
all these,
you know,
these air hangers,
like they're doing some nutty shit out there,
man.
They're,
they're like,
that's where they're making like shuffling stealth bombers and yeah,
that's just the shit on and stuff.
Yeah,
there's video technology's bad acid as it is.
He's 30 fucking years old.
I think a lot of what they're doing is drones.
Man.
There's,
there's a fascinating theme of these people.
This is before they shut it down,
these people were watching like from,
you know,
like some parks spot and they were filming these things flying through the air
and like,
you know,
you never seen anything move like this.
And I'm like,
well that's probably because there's no people in it.
It's probably like drone.
They're probably all drones.
Exactly like this,
but small.
Yeah,
exactly.
Be blackbirds.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what I mean?
We know that they have them now.
We know that they have them.
So if that's what they saw in 1996 and shit when people were filming,
that's probably the answer to a lot of this UFO bullshit.
Well,
I don't believe in Ufos.
I don't,
I think the type traveled is,
is a closer,
uh,
thing in the distance or they're creating some kind of wearable,
but that'll don't believe in aliens.
I don't think,
I think that they exist.
I just don't think they've ever been here.
I'm not convinced that they have or haven't.
I could,
I could see it argued either way.
It sounds totally preposterous when you watch like those ancient aliens shows,
when you see that guy with the crazy hair,
I'm talking all this nonsense about,
you know,
how they believe that.
Well,
you know,
aliens taught all these different people,
all these different things.
But you know,
look,
if we are people,
okay and we have aspired to travel and we supposedly had been to the moon,
if we have that sort of capability in our primitive stage of development,
whatever,
there's a culture,
a hundred thousand 200,000,
300,000 years older than us,
that's nothing in the limit of time.
That's nothing.
So culture that survives by the media culture that survives,
it's two or 3 million years older than us.
They're going to so fucking
far ahead of us that they would literally be able to bypass all the ideas or,
or have come to a resolution on all the ideas about interrupting life and
genetically engineering new life.
To them it would be like,
yeah,
of course you do it.
This is what you do.
You just make your lives.
Yeah,
we'd go there and we introduced our genetics into these monkey genetics and
these monkeys have this crazy thing happens where their brain doubles over a
period of 2 million years and they become humans.
Did that happen?
I don't know.
But there's a lot of fucking stories,
a law,
all of these different stories from so many different religions and so many
different ancient texts all have to do with some higher being coming from the
sky.
You mean what the fuck man?
A little bit though that people would just want to believe in something.
Maybe it's possible.
I mean humans,
I mean it's not an either or,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not an either or.
We don't souls.
You're a survivor at this point that you come from a long line assholes.
You know,
we were the guys who ate the last bit of food.
We were the ones that didn't share during famine,
you know,
and that easy.
I know what you're saying,
but not really.
You know,
all you have to do is get a group of cool people together to fight off the
assholes and you survive as well.
You don't have to be an asshole to survive.
It can be the cool,
smart people that get together and fight off the acid.
So just because we're here doesn't mean where the children of assholes.
But it ain't crazy.
Every,
I mean like every just barbaric.
I mean,
well you know,
from the fucking Mayans to fuck everybody in Europe,
the different clans,
you know,
they were just barbarians.
I mean just the fucking hunts that you know,
we like one when is,
it's six people have the same DNA as gang is Kong or some shit cause he was
calm.
He comes out of the steps of Mongolia and the fucking sweeps in and takes almost
the whole world in that fucking amazing.
I mean grasp it was fucking gangster.
Wouldn't it be awesome to be able to get real documentary footage?
Like the coolest fucking thing would be,
you can't travel through time,
but what you can do is go back in time and watch it and record it.
Well,
you know,
if you imagine on a way to extract it from trees,
thousand year old tree would see what scene.
Technically in a sense,
we're just reflecting light and that's all our OER.
Okay.
And light travels at,
this is the ultimate stoner talk right here.
Why were you in Guam by the way?
Like,
it's like it's been bothered for,
fuck,
I forgot that we were talking about that.
I was just talking about this.
I love this,
this shit man.
I ain't getting high and fucking talking about what I'm talking about.
Hold on,
let me finish the point.
And then if I could tell you about was dude,
check it out.
That if you could go fast than the speed of light to the time and then with the
powerful enough,
uh,
telescope pointed at us to catch the light reflected.
Okay.
You could use just as satellite technology looks down on the earth,
you could see the reflection of the earth from that time and visually prove
everything you wanted to.
Well,
what if you went faster out in the space?
Okay,
you go faster on the space and then you had of lattice scope.
You have a telescope that could look back and capture the light that's coming
off the earth delight that's coming from the earth as you go.
You would theoretically be looking at earth at that point,
the reflection of the light.
So you could see looking at earth at that point in time.
So at the speed of light,
Earth's history would come at you or me if you could visually swatch it.
Who are the clothes that you would be a thousand years in the future looking at
thousand years in the past.
So you'd really more than a thousand moment,
theoretically it would still freeze.
It would still be the exact same distance between earth and you at all points.
So those are the same,
but that that doesn't matter.
It's the no,
it's the,
the backyards that light,
that light reflects off of it.
So you could catch an image of what it might not be a perfect image.
Right.
So as you're going 10 million miles an hour,
it's as it's a million miles away.
Yeah.
It,
no,
no.
If you light the light,
the light,
there's a guy,
I know what you're saying with the idea behind it is if you move into the future
faster than the speed of light,
what happens back here moves at a much,
much,
much faster pace.
No,
no.
What I'm saying is,
is that that the light that bounces off the earth,
okay.
Has an image and that image is the same.
I'm traveling off the earth at the speed of light.
If you go out into space and faster than the speed of light.
So you can't you Mac before it.
Yeah,
you can look back at the image of the earth with a powerful enough telescope.
All right.
And see the history of earth come forward.
Whoa.
Okay.
So you're saying that if you go forward like some fucking insane like if you
went faster than light Alpha Centauri,
what's bad for you?
See the earth,
if we have the kind of technologies that will allow you to,
even though your billions of light years away or however far,
the farther away you are to look back and see the earth and get close to the
actually to the ground so you can even from a hundred million light years away
you still have full view of the earth.
It wouldn't be full.
It would be obscured.
There would be,
you know there's dark patches and only the light that bounces off as the sunny
side.
You can see the sunny side of the earth.
Yes.
You couldn't catch anybody cause people do fucked up shit at night.
You'd be doing the real fucked up shit.
You Ain't get nothing.
No proof on me,
mother fucker.
You could say you saw a shadow in the window,
but she don't know nothing.
Fuck you.
That's saying I'm not going for court.
All right.
I'm just saying.
I see what you're saying though.
It's trippy.
Total stoner thought right there should be taught what should be talking about.
The idea of
time itself is very trippy and especially because it's limited,
you know,
limited.
We are,
our physical bodies find it limited,
but when you get past our physical bodies and all other physical bodies,
that time is just sort of fly.
It's one thing,
just one big gigantic moment,
which is we don't,
last time's only important to us.
That's the real mind.
Fuck.
That's Daddy's.
Exactly it.
The real mind fuck is.
Then you're dying.
Soon as you're born,
you're dying.
When it to,
I watched a fucking guy get killed by a bear today.
Somebody put it up,
broken board.
It was a train.
It was a train bear.
And,
uh,
the train bear had been in movies before,
man and the,
the fucking guy,
he's a gentleman and this bear in the,
in this pan and they're trained in it and doing things with it age just turns on
this guy out of nowhere and rips his throat apart and just tears at it and shit.
Yeah.
That's why I never want to go up in this space and look at the future.
The past dozen years,
fuckings bears up there.
Just the promos for that shit,
undiscovered discovery or whatever it is,
and that makes his fishing nace to grizzly bears.
And I just went the grizzly bear to go,
fuck you.
I'm you and you.
I got you.
And even during the Grizzly man movie,
all right,
it's your ass.
I'm coming and does attack the fucking boat and very frightening there.
Fucking,
they are powerful animals,
man.
They go rip all horse his fucking head off.
Paul.
I've talked about it too much over the past few weeks and I talked about it
yesterday on the Tom Green podcasts,
but there's a video you should see folks.
It's a bear eating a moose alive and it's on the Internet.
You want to know how ruthless fucking nature is,
man.
They're fucking broke it all down and kill you man.
They just start eating.
Yeah,
and we'll get down on the eat you while you're still playing Jack.
Kill me.
Fires this video though.
The crazy thing is,
is a trained bear.
This guy had raised this pair and trained it and his,
his,
I believe it was his cousin was in the rink with it.
You know,
as they were working with the bear and the bear just for whatever reason,
just decided to attack him outta nowhere.
Unprovoked.
Just fucked him up,
man.
You think so?
Really?
Why are you fucking with a bear?
It's a bear.
It's just to make some money.
That's what he does.
Fire trainer.
But somebody has got to do,
like if you've got to have a movie where you have a guy wrestle a bear,
someone's got to train that fucking pair.
We can't have a moving CGN.
Yeah.
You ever see that movie Congo?
Yes.
When they had those big crazy monkeys that were so obviously man with monkey
suits.
It was annoying.
Man.
Gai is fixed.
All of it.
It wasn't working then.
Oh,
that's my favorite earthquake joke.
How dare you brown you Neil earthquake,
the convenient and quick,
what did he say?
He said that he went on a edition and so for planet of the apes to tell Michael
Clarke Duncan in there,
and he called his agent just left.
He said that what the fuck it didn't need makeup
is,
is there
even in Guam,
there's earthquake trying to get back to the garage.
Do you know they're protected by the Mariana Church?
The lowest place on their protected by it.
Yeah.
He protected by the lowest spot on her.
Um,
the,
uh,
the immense cavern,
takes out a lot of the energy from the tsunami.
The how deep the water gets.
Really?
Yeah.
So they are protected by a reef and the predicted protected by the Mariana
showed them had been jacked by a tsunami.
No,
they come,
but they don't get the full width and breadth of it.
You know,
a lot of the energy is lost in the canyon is that trench where they recorded
that insane biological sound.
I know there's the called the bloop.
There's one crazy sound that they recorded that so many times louder than
anything they'd ever recorded that was biological under the water and they know
it was biological.
I don't know what it was.
It's like mayhem under all day,
man.
That guy is,
he's a little much right baby.
I love that guy.
I met him at this a serious spectrum.
That guy is a killer and look in his eyes and I'm like,
yeah,
that's a good,
I had a lot of love to hurt me.
Well,
like it'd be just a goat choice fighting.
Yeah.
Who enjoys it and he's fucking good at it.
He likes it and that's what he's supposed to be doing.
Yeah.
There's a broad spectrum of human beings.
Yeah,
man,
I totally agree.
Everybody's supposed to be doing their thing.
You know,
times people find their thing and it matches up with their personality and
sometimes it's,
if I didn't mention,
if he didn't get into,
can you imagine if he didn't get into fighting and instead he was like,
ah,
I'm just going to work at toys r us and like you're just like,
Oh God,
I'm sorry.
Welcome fallen day waiting to happen.
That would be a problem one day waiting to happen.
Yeah,
that would be a fucking problem.
Like I'm always nervous about any bravo late at night.
Why have you seen him drunk?
I've seen him drunk.
And just the idea that you,
anytime he wants it is very scary.
And the fact that there was nothing I could do and,
and then he tells guys that are like double this size,
how he'd choke them out from underneath.
Okay.
And I've never been heard.
I never even heard that.
I didn't know what that was.
And he's laughing about it.
Oh yeah I do.
I'd climb up on guy and then like fucking leg lock came and choke him out and
shit like this.
And I'm like,
it's so weird cause I don't get that from Eddie Bauer as well as I do with
mayhem.
Like with Manheim,
I fear,
what am Eddie,
he's always just so happy and nice
competing.
Yeah.
You know the differences.
The guys that are competing guys are like actively fighting and MMA.
They all are super,
they have to always be ready to train and to spar.
And the orange thinking about competition,
they're always training.
They're always ramped up,
you know?
And most of them were really calm,
like may Hamm's is about as exaggerated a personalities.
Exactly.
But that's just who he is.
He's always been like that.
I've known that dude forever.
Well you have to,
he's always been like that.
But just the,
that they're in competition mode.
That's like some primal shit.
You're at nine all the time.
You know your,
your senses are heightened,
you know,
you're training for combat,
man.
That's like some serious shit.
[inaudible] imagine that every day.
Like from like,
from like the Spartans,
how they,
you know,
they'd get their kids kidnapped and taken and beaten and fucking tough up and
toughened up.
You know,
you know,
and then they,
they escape at 18 and they go rape and steal a girl out at night.
You know,
it was part of was fucking,
I mean,
these guys,
they were warriors.
It's crazy when you think about what pussies we are today and that people had to
be like that at one point in time for us to get till today.
They had to be strong.
They had to be able to fight off fucking animals and hordes of invading tribes.
You how to be strong,
to stay alive just a few thousand years ago.
Crazy isn't it?
It's,
it's strange.
Hundred 5,050 fucking year,
two lifetimes.
Do the wild west.
That was the 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
Matt.
18.
Great.
65 was the abolition of slavery,
right?
Was it 1875 or 1865.
65.
And then you've got,
you know,
fucking cowboys and Indians going to war war,
just fucking knife fighters.
Well,
those guys are nasty.
Did you see the thing we're,
we're,
um,
Obama got in trouble because he,
uh,
was,
talking about sitting bull and recognizing the sitting bull was a hero and you
know,
that it was like,
Eh,
I guess it was a part of some book that he has.
He has some child book and uh,
people are going,
hey,
sitting bowl like killed like a lot of fucking Americans.
Yeah.
It's funny because we're acknowledging now that we've integrated the American
Indian into the whole American culture,
like they are part of us now.
We're sort of acknowledging that the original Americans just fuck them,
you know?
And there's this guy fought back and this guy's a hero for fighting essentially
us.
Well,
you know,
it's mind boggling when when you say,
we're,
we're the land of the free because of an act of terrorism to Willie Nelson.
He's in fucking going to be in jail,
my deck.
But you know,
we say that,
you know,
we,
we espouse this patriotism and stuff and,
and if you go to the Boston tea party,
which is fucking,
which is dumb dumbs Republicans that are mad that we have a black guy or saying,
you know,
were tea party is okay,
they're fucking kind of talking about a terrorist act.
That was a terrorist act.
It was not an act of war.
You know that,
right?
We call it rebellion because we're all in this fucking side of it.
But it was a book and basically a terrorist act if an,
if,
if white guys today dressed up as,
as that Arabs,
okay.
And attacked a private company and destroyed property,
we'd call it a terrorist act.
Okay.
All right.
And that's exactly what we did.
Right?
Okay.
It's tariffs act.
Yeah,
I know.
And that's how we bought our nation.
And the same thing that,
you know,
we accused Afghanistan being terrorist because they want to kill us or they
killed this many,
and they don't want to be under our fucking rule out there.
We'd be an empire like the fucking British where to us?
Well,
we're a lot crazier than that.
We're more crazy than any empire ever.
We have military presence in over a hundred countries.
Do you know what that means yet?
We've got guns all over the world and jets and some American soldiers ready to
go at anytime.
What's up,
dude?
It's ready to go.
Strategically placed and all sorts of areas of it can get jets to them in time.
Are you nervous about this fucking North Korea guy?
No.
No,
not at all.
No.
I think he just wants better trade agreements.
That's not going to die.
They don't have any food.
He's about to die.
He's already named on the same,
nothing's going to happen.
But look how,
look at his son now.
His son's ready to jump in,
but,
and he looks like he's a nice young guy that played starcraft and he's going to
finally dad's gone.
I could play starcraft with all my friends.
Play Star craft.
I mean he's not as fun.
Once you have nuclear weapons,
you can use telling you,
man,
it was like a bomb the fuck out of that island.
They attacked an island,
right?
They shelled the shit out of the four hours.
They flattened it.
Really?
And what was on the island?
Who was on the island?
They kill people.
Yes.
They killed thousands,
supposedly.
Really?
It was like
you heard it was seven thought,
seven people to induces a retard.
We should go Google.
Yeah.
Uh,
South Korean sailors,
they down to fucking ship.
And he said,
and then they said they didn't motherfucker,
we got you on tape when they fucking blew up a battleship and not about a ship.
It's like a trawler,
uh,
of the South Korea navy.
They blew it up and killed 47 sailors.
That's an act of war.
Two dudes died.
Two dudes on the shell and they both died of aids.
They both had to hit
to our conversation.
And this is numbers.
I think we need to leave out numbers until we know these bitches.
It's two people died,
Bro.
To dose those humans does humans and the shelling.
That's it.
Oh my God.
Well,
what about the 47 sales?
That's still people that fucking died,
man.
Praise crazy.
That guy's killing people.
Yeah,
he's killing people and there,
yeah,
it looks like the Berlin checked.
Well,
maybe you're right.
Maybe he's so fucked up.
He is going to try to actually go out with a bang.
You never know.
You never know,
man.
Don't underestimate cookoo.
You've gotta be pretty crazy to want to be,
uh,
some sort of a leader like that.
A leader of a country.
We didn't ever call lear of anything to be that arrogant that you should be the
main person.
It's mean,
it's really just playing up on a flaw in human nature,
law law as the,
the necessity of the Alpha where we're always looking to the one person that we,
we are going to be led by.
That's how all tribes of animals deal with tribes of wolves.
Do it tribes,
a monkeys do it and tribes of humans to it.
We need one person.
Even though one person isn't qualified,
as long as there's one person in that position.
That's why you know the cell Sarah Palin thing is possible.
You don't have to be qualified.
You just have to be in the position.
You know this.
This fucking guy isn't qualified to be the president North Korea.
You're telling me other than North Korean people haven't said,
listen,
I'm a lot more reasonable.
I could get shit done with other countries
like that as a cabbage in every pot and the ground chicken in every pot.
Yeah,
you gotta be,
you gotta be really twisted motherfucker to want to run things.
Fucking rockets that hit off the shore of Hawaii.
Hawaii.
Wow.
You've got enough fuck up.
Why I Hawaii is awesome.
I was there after Guam to fuck up Hawaii.
Well,
what if they fuck up?
If they're willing to fuck up these people on this island,
man,
let me tell you what the fact there's over a million infantry of North Korea.
That's what people do there.
They don't make anything.
Everybody is fucking in the army.
It's true.
All right.
If they wanted to walk over South Korea,
there's nothing we could do with 28,500 US troops right there except for
battlefield nukes to prevent it.
Do you understand the complete wipe out and within hours they could take soul.
All of it be gone.
All of it.
Really.
How much w w how many troops does and the United States have their 28,500 I
think that's plenty.
It's not put the shit we got sun.
Well yeah.
Well that's what I'm saying.
Cause that battlefield nukes,
there's no way to do it.
They got jets.
Don't they have like Janssen fucking do they have jets?
They're all the same shit.
Whether they get Soviet shit.
Yeah and Chinese shit.
Tiny shit.
Mother fuckers,
man man,
they fucking be Nike's.
Let me tell you what they can fuck up a jet that would make a fast Mig.
Yeah,
and they got a lot of them and they got a shit load of numbers to,
that's the real of sheer numbers.
You couldn't stop.
That.
Real crazy thing is China and if you really wanted to have a country,
if we are,
we're in a situation like we used to have like with the United States versus
Russia.
When I was a kid it was always everyone was worried that Russia was going to the
United States.
Yeah.
Red Dog and pony boy motherfuckers.
Yeah,
there was,
everybody was concerned that something we were going to eventually get involved
in some sort of a nuclear exchange and you always heard,
oh we almost came to a nuclear exchange was a mistake and we got out of it and
luckily cooler heads prevail.
We play again,
plane and shit.
That was just,
I mean that was just a little while ago man.
We kind of forgot what that's like.
But China,
he's in the position to be that again.
Yeah.
They are ruthless people.
They are ruthless,
ruthless and there's so many of them.
They look,
if you want some of the HBO show for,
I think some of the shit that's going down in China right now.
You know,
it's a really popular,
what's happening a lot.
People selling their kids.
Yeah.
People are having their kids and it's selling them and they,
they're like five and six years old.
So hot right now.
Shelly is cooperation.
Horrifying man.
There was a whole show on it where this brother,
his brother was five and his brother was kidnapped and they kidnapped his
brother instead of him because he was eight and he would've known how to get
home.
So they kidnap this fucking five year old and took him away and he sold it.
His father sold it and his father's talking about him.
He had to sell one of his sons and he didn't want to,
but he had to do it.
So we went with the younger one because he didn't,
uh,
he didn't know any better and he could trick them or something along those
lines.
But you know,
he's talking about how the,
he was really upset that the,
uh,
the,
the older boy was a,
was still mad at him about it,
but these kids are probably the kids that are smoking cigarettes where you see
on like the youtube videos and stuff.
You're like,
yeah,
this guy's a dick.
I would sell them for $5.
He's,
you know,
self,
a note and all my cigarettes out at all.
And a little boy,
man,
the little boy whose his brother was left behind.
It was really heartbreaking.
It's talking about missing his brother and how his brother,
and he was so mad at his father that his,
you know,
his father sold his brother.
I was like,
you gotta be fucking shitting me man.
It all the time.
It's wearing him to corporations.
These weren't dirty clothes and he's in his fucking shack,
you know,
this little shack with his dad and his dad is trying to explain how he needed
the money.
I'm like,
it's like,
um,
you know,
the only way to citizenship basically like enrollment times is to be in the
army,
you know,
to go from poverty to grace and stuff is to aid,
have intellect.
Okay.
I show,
you know,
and an aptitude for military service or science or math or you know,
athletics or you go to the fucking drones in Japan,
China.
I mean in China you have to be,
you saw everybody joins the military and trying to,
yeah,
it's got a huge fucking military.
Tiggers or military.
I want to hear a number.
I know you got one in your head come up.
It's so supposedly the third largest overall,
their largest incorporate it to power strength,
my own power rating as number three,
but on sheer numbers if they want it to because they have like the national guys
that were there and people are,
you know that that aren't in certain areas.
They're like the national guard.
Even though they might work at a factory.
Also if you,
you know,
enlist those militia.
It's the largest army in the world by number.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Way By number and then,
but by power it's only number two.
It's a whole interesting the life that they have their man,
you know this,
all the shit that's going down with these companies that have people working
insane hours and people are jumping off buildings and shit.
Like just wait.
The whole con comm thing.
I read something that was kind of an interesting rebuttal to that con comm
because it talked about all the suicides and con comm habit.
Then it mode noted that con comm has over 500,000 employees.
So is that an above average?
It's not really.
It's not as compared to the population.
No,
it's not.
And you know,
yeah,
they're,
they're working shitty jobs,
man.
Those jobs suck.
They just suck and you're going to work in a factory assembly line.
Yeah.
Guess what?
It's not going to be a,
it goes into the hall.
You know why?
Because Walmart wants to save 17 cents per.
Yeah.
I wouldn't start selling kids.
I'm like,
I could get like $10,000 selling my kids.
I'll just have a baby factory.
I don't think they're that much.
They're not even that much bigger grant and got way better than that.
What does that make six months of work though at one of those iPod factories
that by the time you're done crying,
that's right.
When your money,
right.
It's got to turn it off.
You've got to turn it off.
You got to turn it off.
It's your kid.
Yeah.
Good luck with that haunted dreams for the rest of your fucking life,
man.
You just sold your son haunted dreams that just goes to show you that man,
the apocalypse that sell me the apocalypse is everywhere.
It's just not here yet.
The apocalypse is everywhere.
There's different lives that are experiencing it all over the world in an
individual basis with individual families and individual situations.
There's apocalypse is all over Africa,
all over parts of the world,
all over the child will holocaust.
It's insane.
The shit that's going down in Africa right now,
if it was happening in your neighborhood,
you would be smarter,
follows the end of the world.
You know what be cool is that run through with machetes and cut people's heads
off and,
and yeah,
there's a lot of hacking to death with machetes and going down kids and getting
them to drug addicted and shooting cocaine and heroin.
America Americans says start franchising itself like as a brand name.
Like,
Hey,
we're going to have an America opening up in your neighborhood and you can have
our laws and rules and protection,
you know,
but it's going to cost you money and it's going to start popping up like
Starbucks.
Just like,
dude,
let's go to the American media in July.
Just employer.
That's a great idea.
We just go to Africa and just jacket.
Yeah.
And then it goes to jack did that Bro.
We did that a lot in Africa.
Well they tried to,
what's going on right now is a,
there's so much war.
Civil war in the Congo is a lot of like expensive shit in the concrete and
stuff.
Yeah,
just found lithium there.
So now there's the next gold rush.
The Congo's.
Uh,
that's
so much rape and crime and scanning shapes.
New End workers,
man.
Like people who've worked for the UN or down,
they're raping and killing.
That's why you need to go to America.
Yeah.
So do you think we can just take,
don't play any music bro.
That's where the food is.
No.
Was we're going to go on Sirius.
So keep doing that.
You're gonna fuck us up mass America.
Yeah,
but you don't know him that,
do y'all know that song?
I'm friends with people that do
call Trey.
Don't say your friends unless you can call that dude right now and go,
Yo,
what up trades.
Right?
He's not going to answer that phone.
He's going to go,
who is this weird fuck?
He's not going to sue you.
You don't know that sir.
You can't.
You get,
you got to get releases for shit.
This is the Karaoke version too.
Oh,
now it makes it good.
What I was saying,
tunes man,
you can't,
I couldn't even hum that song,
that door song in my,
my a comedy central special.
I couldn't go.
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo man couldn't do that.
You can't do that because someone owns that.
And you know what?
No one gave me any shit when I sampled a Kung Fu fighting in my,
uh,
second special.
You sampled it.
Do you mean you got on stage and sang it?
Yeah,
I hummed it.
Hmm.
Well,
Carl Douglas is,
is there a time where music becomes everyone's property?
Isn't there like some sort of a thing that happens with books and literature
wherever they live become property?
Like what does the term I think it is,
I think it's,
you know,
like you can't see you,
the Christmas songs,
you know,
like anyone can sing a Christmas domain song,
public domains.
That's exactly what the term is.
Public domain.
Yeah.
Does that happen with with every song or I don't take certain socks.
I mean it should really have to like a hundred years or something like that.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno man.
You know it's,
it's,
you know,
there's somebody who gets paid on happy birthday.
Yeah,
that's pretty nuts.
Like when you go to Bennigan's,
I can't sing happy birthday,
so we have some version of it.
The gross,
just do it and see if you get away with it.
You know where they're going.
They're going to sue Bennigan's all over the world.
They come at birth and that's just gross.
Whoever would do that,
man,
what a piece of shit anymore.
You're calling him you and happy birthday just because you own that shit on
paper as you mean your own happy birthday.
You fucking Weirdo.
I know it to everybody's well,
we added Pat.
How can you own that shit's been around forever.
Forever.
There's someone actually write that.
Yeah.
Two people apparently I doubt it.
That's what they say.
Hey,
let's get together and make a song together.
Do Man,
they sit down and try to come up with a catchy lingo.
People following you right now?
Uh,
W on what?
On,
on this stuff.
On Twitter gathers twitters.
Oh no shit.
See that's why you need to get into Twitter cause he,
I mean it's,
it's like hey,
I'm in Chicago right now.
What's the best place to eat?
You'll get instant answers or what's the best place to work?
Can I get some weed?
You know,
instant answers answered those questions myself.
It's like instant information now.
It's,
it's,
it's like can't you just did it yourself?
It's text messaging like 8,000 people at once or how many ever followers or you
are so you can send shit out.
That's amazing.
Yeah that's a lot of power.
It's interesting.
I mean cause you have,
you have the,
the combined knowledge of 8,000 possibly if they were all online at the same
time.
Well just one question.
So you have the population,
you definitely get good answers to a lot of shit.
And if you are,
if you're an interesting person and you went to things that you know fascinating
things about science and space and I know you are,
when you tweak those,
if you find something online and you find some story,
like,
wow,
check this shit out.
You know,
they just invented Bam and you put that link up,
you'll put that link up.
A bunch of dudes will retweet that link and then they'll start sending you shit,
Hey Ralphie,
I know you're into this space.
Shit,
check this out.
They just discovered this doom and that's what's going on in black about harp
shortly after the heart.
Yes.
That's fucking amazing.
What have you heard
that we are,
we're are secretly having a war at,
we are attacking,
uh,
Pakistan,
China,
India,
um,
uh,
Bangladesh and Indonesia,
that whole area or region,
uh,
through bending the ionosphere with massive radio waves.
So what do we do in Alaska?
We're causing flooding like,
like beyond a all time that's ever been recorded.
Um,
concentration of earthquakes,
um,
that we were relieving the pressure that we're moving the ionosphere where,
where are you getting all this?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
H No,
I'm not sure.
That's what I'm saying.
I mean are you sure?
I know what you're saying.
I know that but I'm saying that the floods this year where the greatest of all
time that they have uh,
according to you as,
as they have a higher rate of wearing a very high earthquake for a Asia Central
Asia and South Asia of all time.
Okay.
Yeah.
But Ralphie that easily could be because the cycles of the earth,
that doesn't mean shit.
The,
that we have only done what we've studied as far as like earthquakes and floods
and you know the history of weather and disasters.
This is,
we're dealing with a tiny fraction of the time but the earth has existed.
Our data is so small.
So when you say something like,
you know there's a record earthquakes,
there's record floods,
the record is like you just woke up and the phone rang and you like this phone
has rang a record number of times today cause it only rang once cause you've
only been awake for five minutes.
Our,
our knowledge of the earth is so fucking minuscule that anytime people get crazy
and start saying things like,
oh,
there's a record number of earthquakes,
it must be because someone's attacking Pakistan with a blight running bolt that
goes into the sky.
It's not necessarily the fact that sounds sexy as fuck.
That sounds sexy as fuck,
man.
I don't think it's that simple.
I think who knows what,
it's a research project.
It's a high frequency active auroral research program.
We don't know exactly what they're doing.
They could be doing a bunch of different things.
They could be trying to charge up the ionosphere,
but the idea that they're somehow the shooting something in the space and
attacking Pakistan,
dude,
someone's bullshitting you cause that is not what's happening.
Okay.
There's just no,
no evidence that points to that at all.
There's no,
no.
There's all these people that want everything to be sexy and they want
everything to be sexy.
They want everything to be,
the government's attacking us from space.
They want everything to be a conspiracy.
And the problem with that kind of thinking is it fucks up the ones that are real
conspiracies.
Cause there's all lot of them.
There's plenty of real that's a real,
because it's a real place and is Dev,
they're definitely doing real research.
But I don't know.
I don't know what that is and I don't think you do either.
And I think until we do know,
you can't really say that.
You can't just go and say their attack in Pakistan with shit from the sky.
No,
but latest theory.
But by who?
Alex Jones is hap retarded,
illegitimate brother.
Woo.
Uh,
I like,
uh,
Jesse Ventura,
but there's a lot of conspiracy should wish from me.
They're in the shit,
ain't got time to listen to him too.
And I think he's another guy that's looking for things to be sexy.
He wants conspiracies.
There's plenty of God damn conspiracies that are real.
But when you start looking for them in everything and saying that,
you know,
you think squirly man,
they're fucking went,
they honest,
fair,
and then bombarding it.
Sure.
But I don't know what they're doing or why they're doing it.
You know,
it could be some sort of weather experimentation.
It could be some sort of experimentation.
As far as recharging the magneto sphere or changing things or keeping the polls
right now,
what they're doing,
I don't know.
I don't have on crazy ram clue.
I know.
That's why I really want to know more about it.
There's a crazy one.
Was a operation starfish prime,
I believe that's what it's called.
They shot a nuke up into space and blew it up.
Yeah,
they loaded a name.
We're fucking danger.
They did in the fifties the Russians did it will.
The Americans did it.
We did move up.
We blew it up in inside the van Allen radiation belts,
like they were going to try to punch a hole through the man.
Allen everything up made it like way more radioactive.
The whole thing is a disaster up there.
It'd be like that for like a billion years and shit.
It's fucking done,
but it fucked that.
It stopped power in a New Zealand to Australia,
to La,
Los Angeles.
It.
The impulse was so much more magnified because where it was,
it's really trippy when you go back in time and look at how many different
things that human beings did where they just took a chance.
Like,
let's see what happens when we just blow up a nuclear bomb and space.
Just shoot it up there and blow it up.
And they all sat around and thought about it and go,
can we do that?
Don't you do that?
Well,
John Wayne made a movie con in the crater of a fucking nuke.
We have surface detonated and then like eight years later they made a film in
the crater.
Really?
That's why everybody on that fucking movie died of cancer.
I did hear that he had done some movie and they filmed it somewhat clear they're
doing nuclear experiments,
but I didn't know they filmed it in the crane.
The fucking crater did.
You can see black Google.
Ralphie may requires a lot of Google.
I'm sorry.
Okay,
so it's a John Wayne.
John Wayne.
Oh,
can I guess con.
Hi,
you spoke,
you lose multiple spellings,
but I think it's g e n G.
H.
I s c.
I s and then con k.
H.
A.
N.
That was the role that he played.
I don't know if it's the name of the movie,
but everybody on that fucking thing from the set directors to catering died of
cancer.
Wow.
Did dingus con nuke John Wayne right away,
man.
Right away.
The stories about it.
Creepy fucking right,
right.
Wow.
No two pack a day.
Smoker and sieve above ground nuclear weapons testing occurred at the test site
as part of operation upshot knothole.
I'm telling you,
man casts when the pictures come from,
she used to do shit back there,
but 1981 91 of them had developed some sort of form of cancer and 46 had died of
the cancer.
Holy Shit.
120 people in the entire cast and crew,
almost half of them.
That would be continuous exposure over multiple weeks,
but they filmed really fast.
Back then.
It wasn't even like it was nowadays.
You know how long they were there for?
Yeah,
but what if they just all eight red m and m's or something like that?
You know?
Like what if it was just something else?
Nothing to do with the fact they weren't afraid of [inaudible] crater.
Blown up by an atomic bomb.
I have like 5,000 years and you're just chilling there filming tag toe.
But I wouldn't feel now what?
Can we get another take on that one?
Yes.
As would you be?
How pissed would you be?
You like you didn't know.
You didn't know?
The actors don't know.
You think John Wayne?
No,
he didn't know.
Nobody knew.
The producers didn't know either.
No one knew where they got cheap shooting.
They fucking knew that long ago,
man.
That's like the 19 fucking sixties and shit.
I'm not so people shit just then.
So it's like 50 years ago,
man,
we didn't know shit.
Amazing.
That's incredible.
Where's your,
where's your survival place?
I Dunno man.
I'll go back to Colorado when the shit hits the fan.
You still have your place in Colorado?
No,
no.
I only least it at least there for a year.
My solely go back there and I save a place would be the shower curled up in the
fetal position.
I'm going to kiss your name down in my mouth before drive off into the
background.
Yeah,
right.
Zombie hordes.
They'll be coming for you son.
Man.
It will get very within days.
Metropolitan areas will be mean with that.
With with the interruption of basic service,
I'd probably go right to Cologne.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
It only needs to be out for a couple of weeks.
What could happen in the fucking horror jump in and Katrina,
terrible man.
I've watched documentaries on that shit and it's just,
it's hard.
It's like anyone civilization just shut down,
shut the fuck down.
And it only took a matter of days.
Tell you why you take fresh water and electricity away from people and they go
fucking cuckoo for cocoa puffs.
It is amazing when you're done well.
Yeah,
no.
When they go animal and it's hot as fuck,
they're stuck very well.
You're not supposed to be there.
The whole cities and I'm supposed to be there.
It's not supposed to be underwater like that.
That's the crazy thing is it's below sea level,
so you have walls up to keep the ocean out.
Holy Shit.
And this is where you share the Mississippi sleep.
Yeah.
They go,
Whoa,
it's awesome,
but why is it awesome?
It's awesome because there's people that are awesome.
Why don't move the awesome people?
It's all make an agreement.
Let's all move are awesome.
They know what they want to do up to higher ground.
If they,
if they hadn't had this recession,
they were talking about,
uh,
the largest,
um,
uh,
public's work,
Vang ever.
They were going to detour the Mississippi to re around the city of New Orleans
to make,
uh,
a Delta,
to protect it all right?
And they were going to reroute the Mississippi.
It's what they will.
Uh,
the corps of engineers had slated as the largest public works larger than the
Hoover Dam,
exponentially larger Jesus Christ and an incredible waste of money.
But they were going to,
you're going to build all this thing that we're going to help.
And the idea is because it's so awesome.
New Orleans is so awesome.
This is why that it needs to be protected.
Oh,
this is kind of crazy man,
because it's not like there's a lack of places to move to cause a lot of spots
in this country you could relocate.
Oh,
how many people are living in New Orleans though?
It's Kinda be like a million,
right?
Yeah.
But you know,
it's a great generator for Louisiana.
Yes.
The real problems,
like moving them quick.
Impossible.
It's just,
there's too many people.
Oh Man.
I know.
Houston is not the same since Katrina,
but they should have sloped.
It's not right.
It's really not.
Dude,
it's gets really fucking night.
It's an,
I mean,
the murder rate,
you know,
went up like 340% dude,
while we were there.
A right afterwards.
And uh,
you could see like all these people that had been displaced or all over the
streets of downtown.
Oh,
this is like way different than it was just a year ago.
Yeah,
man.
He whole New Orleans things gonna suck because New Orleans,
like everybody talks about how great the city is.
Like people fucking loved that place.
They love it and love it and that,
that's what it's like in this shit spot.
Like fuck man.
You can what I was saying that he nonsense.
You really could never move it.
You would never recreated it.
Wouldn't work.
It wouldn't,
it's a terrible idea.
But you know,
it'd be busy.
Too Bad.
They didn't slowly like fucking creep back into an area and keep New Orleans but
slowly lists a lot of people in new water will hit.
I,
I lived in new Elantra like six months to gym.
I was cooking at Nolas and um,
there's a lot of people in New Orleans that believe again,
because it happened once in the 60s during,
I think it was Camille,
that white people from a lake potch train blew up.
Dynamited the the levees.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause that spike Lee conspiracy.
Now that's a fact.
It's a fact.
And that,
and that people heard loud explosions that were still on their rose.
Majority of them died when they drown.
But okay,
so these people,
they blew up the levees to drown the black people.
No to drain lake Pontchartrain cause it's Lake Pontchartrain with the Ma bell
largest amount of water you're keeping back.
Okay.
So in the areas that happen to bay or the nights they want,
why they want to do that to save the white communities on punching the really
expensive homes.
Oh,
okay.
So they took it upon,
those homes were going to get encroached by water.
Yeah.
The water was about was about the flood.
So they jacked it buddy
by breaking it dams and then killing a bunch of people,
much people must've died.
Right?
Yeah.
That's where I think 95% of the casualties from Katrina happened was the
flooding.
And people go,
you know,
you've got time.
And it's like,
no,
you're not.
You know what I mean?
That water's coming in and like,
you know,
a foot every second fuck.
Yeah.
And it's like you can't,
when the fuck you go fucking knock a hole in your house because there's water
outside up to the second floor,
crazy.
And you're stuck in the attic and that outside,
it's 108 degrees and a your bacon.
And that's when people die.
Wow.
And there was a big,
big,
big problem with the amount of response and the quickness.
They're responsible.
Yeah,
man.
I mean we can,
you know,
18 hours we can be in fucking Afghanistan with 10,000 troops in 18 hours.
We couldn't go to New Orleans.
There's no money.
There's no money in being able to go to New Orleans.
It's crazy,
man.
Money isn't going to countries with tanks and taking care of business.
It's like,
you know,
and it's a Cooper's.
They're going,
hey was,
hey,
this is cell phone and shit.
Oh well we don't want to see it.
And we watch Fox News and Bill O'reilly says that those black people should've
left and fuck him.
No,
no,
he did not say that.
No,
no.
But he just gives off attitude.
Fox News gives off a,
a actually a attitude that's shared by a lot of people that those people know
that the hurricane was coming and they should just leave.
And,
but life on the Gulf,
if you ever lived there,
I mean,
you never think you're going to get fucking hit this.
Yeah.
You have parties.
And the truth is that a power is out for a week,
week and a half,
two weeks.
If you could take it,
fuck it,
there'll be ice,
you know,
you'll be able to stay in your house and you won't get looted.
All right?
But you're also talking about people who are dirt poor and don't have a
disposable,
you know,
in case the fucking hurricane hits right now,
of course I've got,
you know,
$500 to take me to Houston telling my relatives are,
well,
on an individual basis,
you could always understand everybody's own problems and getting out of there.
But if you look at it objectively there,
right?
The people who are saying,
why are they living there?
They're right.
You really shouldn't be living in a place where you're that close to some sort
of core of engineers is fucked it up.
I mean,
you know,
the core of engineers fucked it up.
Yeah.
When they,
when they dredged and they put the inner coastal channel in,
they,
they stopped the,
um,
the wetlands from being formed.
The Natural Delta effect of the,
of the Mississippi has to meander and they fixed it so they had proper channels
to for shipping or you know,
and,
and what's happening is it's eroding coastline and coastline is going farther
and farther back.
I said,
mate,
constantly built up.
It's being,
it's being allowed to erode and that's why hurricanes over the future are going
to be more damaging to the city of New Orleans.
And why is that important?
Because 80% of,
well,
I know as soon as Katrina happened,
there was no fuel in Nashville.
There was no fuel,
there was no gas stations.
All right?
And it got crazy quick and people were like having to go out and see their
neighbor and say,
Hey,
uh,
do you,
do you have gas?
Yes I do.
I need to go shop.
And I do too.
Great.
Then when you want to go,
all right.
It was crazy.
You know,
we have enough gas to go shopping in Nashville.
How long is this going for?
It was gone on for like two and a half weeks and it didn't happen in Georgia
too.
It happened.
It happened a lot of states.
We were in Atlanta while that was going down and the people were talking about
it when we're working at the,
um,
the punchline and the employees were talking about,
yeah,
there was no gas and people were waiting in line giant lines to get in giant
lines and,
and as soon as you say you would,
you would,
uh,
people were going on their CBS and Internet and looking for,
trucks.
I mean,
you know,
any truck,
any tanker that was going through,
uh,
was being diverted to,
and we don't understand how close we are to the tip.
It does.
We are less than eight hours away from total catastrophe at anytime.
God dammit,
Ralphie May.
Why are you bringing this doom and gloom positive?
I'm trying to be positive and I'm just trying to tell you that you're right to
train and be,
you have saved and be fucking,
you know,
closer to your chimp.
All right?
Because we are very close,
you know,
with our fucking iPhones and everything like this and twittering and all this
shit.
You know,
we've got this amazing amount of power that electromagnetic pulse would knock
out completely.
All right.
Or,
or say,
say fucking a new terrorist,
you know,
instead of,
instead of going for the fucking towers,
all right.
They flew into that fucking Indian river flooding a nuclear facility,
you know,
that's between Poughkeepsie in New York and it radiated all in New York or hyper
Novas.
I was watching this doc,
hyper Novas and other galaxies,
these hyper Novas.
Um,
the first,
when they first started recording him,
they had no idea that anything could emit this much power.
Hyper Novas have so much power.
They have more power than all the stars in the sky combined.
And they happen all the time.
They happen all the time.
A couple times a day.
They're like all throughout the day they're happening.
And these waves,
these massive waves of energy that cosmic rays,
and it's this just fucking massive Super Nova Sun exploding.
Yvette rip that which destroy the entire galaxy.
Just cut through it and just rape everything.
Leave everything in there and dead and just,
it would start a new cook,
the galaxy and then it's going off pop pop.
He said going off,
dude,
it's fucking mind blowing.
What's out there,
you know,
look at what could kill all of us.
It was a great special on PBS.
I don't know if you saw it.
I don't need to watch that shit.
Think like that all the time.
Or is this at Walmart and somebody stabs you?
You know,
you're a kid in Milwaukee.
Scared of Walmart,
Walmart guess.
Yeah.
And that's just tons of weapons there.
Someone pulled a knife on you at Walmart.
Oh No,
no,
no.
In my face.
That's true to some douchebag.
Cholo supernova.
I want to start some shit.
Cosmically we were wearing chargers.
Jerseys.
All right.
We got stabbed by Raiders,
man.
Dude,
I was watching something,
reading some article online about dirt.
They're watching these two galaxies collide somewhere and the know they're just
like starting to,
uh,
record this galaxies hit each other,
dude.
Yes.
I'm thinking about that shit.
Like you knew you could get hit by a planet.
Everything has gravity.
So you know,
the sun is the most dense thing and on the solar system,
all right.
And it's spinning in something more dense to make it spin in that area that
rotates something else that's even denser to cause it to have a gravity,
uh,
gravitational spin while exponentially spaces expanding out to infinity.
And it just fucking blows your mind.
And when you start listening to Carl Sagan and you start listening to,
you know,
I'm a Stephen Hawking,
you shit like that.
It's fucking mind blowing with these amazing,
whereas calm as we are about at all,
it's amazing.
We just kind of have to just accept it,
accept a certain level of anxiety and panic.
And it's like,
you know,
of,
of what the fuck.
And there we got her back to religion.
It's not me,
it's God.
The big thing with the real serious conspiracy theorists is the 2012 thing.
Ah,
big one.
And now 12.
And you know,
Maya Piru Annunaki connection that that's when the big planet that's on an
elliptical orbit that's 3000,
600 years away.
It comes around and comes into our atmosphere every,
you know,
3000,
600 years.
And that's where we learned everything.
That's where the Annunaki came from and they taught us how to mine for gold for
them.
It's pretty trippy,
dude.
That's great.
I love it,
man.
This guy's Zachariah died passed between us and the moon at big meteor.
Um,
which time salad?
A bunch of times.
I mean the one that just happened like a month ago.
No,
I didn't pay attention to that.
Is it a big one?
It was big as a semi.
Really?
Yeah.
It hits,
it explodes in the fuck atmosphere.
And we have what they didn't say Barry in 1980 what it really,
yeah.
And something that's that size could do that.
Wow.
It's fucking amazing.
You know that plane,
the plane that we're talking about,
the um,
the supersonic jet was going 2000 miles an hour,
right?
Yeah.
The asteroids that hit a lot of them are going 45,000 miles an hour.
Stop and think about that.
Vaporization
screaming through space and slamming into the earth.
The one that killed the dinosaurs within the first second,
it was five miles deep into the earth.
Wow,
that's amazing.
And that's what off the Yucatan peninsula,
right within the first second,
it was five miles
deep into the skin.
Even.
You won't even see that.
Like maybe on the other side.
No,
it's the speed of light.
It would just be a flash and then you'd be gone.
Dude,
that would devastated.
And you know what?
Suck harder living you.
Couldn't you fucking live through that?
He wouldn't just some scurrying.
It would cause massive steel and rat.
If this thing hits like,
like it did,
I mean it would turn the continents over.
The ultimate trip to think that 65 million years ago there was none of this.
There was none of us.
One to nothing even close.
No flowering plants.
Everything was totally different.
65 million years crazy and giant lizards that just fucked each other up all day.
They ate each other.
Giant lizards capable.
He's,
they found out a t rex was a huge cannibal.
That's the most recent discovery.
Huge cattle,
everything each other.
That one dinosaur didn't even exist.
Those I don't even the triceratops.
Yeah,
well they found out it existed.
No,
it exists,
but they didn't know that it was just a mature version of another dinosaur.
What if there was only one dinosaur that lived in was a huge alien that ate all
these other creatures and barfed it out throughout the earth.
You know that,
that none of these animals actually even lived on earth.
It was just a another alien barfed it everywhere and it's like this big alien
just like bar and they bought that for 250 million years.
That adds up to the carpet dating all these fossils.
The fuck's wrong with you man.
You live in a cartoon.
He's,
it was just this one huge dinosaur that visited earth once in a while.
He like,
Hey,
let's to go barf on earth where a bit,
what if we're just a toilet?
We don't hear it.
Ryan,
you got brain damage,
like need to find that.
That's what happened actually makes more sense than a lot of things.
Oh,
it only makes sense.
No,
I agree with you that a big giant dinosaur barfed out all these dinosaurs that
are here.
That's totally what I know.
Bones from eating them.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's totally get it out.
Who should it out?
He ate 'em all over hundreds of millions of years.
He told her this and trust the entire evolutionary chain where you can see
whether,
you know they had like wags and then all of a sudden their spaces because we
don't know what's happened.
What's away.
That's what I'm saying.
That one dinosaur they gave you just said didn't exist.
Just found out it was a younger version of another dinosaur.
Yeah.
So all these other species and all these other dinosaurs,
we don't have any idea of this dinosaur is this dinosaur.
You know,
we find out new shit all the time.
We find out new shit all the time,
but they know most of what happened.
The thing.
The only thing is,
it's really weird about any fossils is that most things when they died do not
leave a fossil.
When you die,
most likely you're not going to leave a fossil.
You leave a fossil if you die in like a mudslide that you leave in a fall,
most of the times you just say as the animals come along and eat your bones and
that's around.
It's the monster likes to eat dinosaurs in mud,
like like,
like,
like bear for instance.
Here's a perfect example.
It's very difficult to find dead bears.
We know bears,
we know bears die all the time,
but you really run into them.
They're bodies that often.
That's because they eat them,
they eat them and ratzy thumb and something hits the bones and coyotes eat them
and the bonds get crushed up and ground up come up on it within like a matter of
a week two,
I don't know how long it takes,
but yeah,
sometimes,
I mean,
I mean I've been walking through the woods in Arkansas and locked up on a deer
carcass.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're a whole deer antlers and everything,
but the point is if you want to find it,
I fossilized dear.
Good luck.
Yeah,
good luck.
Good luck.
I mean,
deer have been around for,
who knows how long,
let's say a million years or so.
It's not long enough to make a fossil.
Where's the fossilized dear?
Well,
it's not our pitch there and shit like that.
Like that.
Perfect example.
The Pleistocene ended just 10,000 years ago.
I just,
I just found out recently that like saber tooth tigers and woolly mammoths,
they exhausted just a little over 10,000 years.
Right.
Where we are around does incredible.
Right where we are.
Wrap your head around that.
Woolly mammoths were just 10,000 years ago.
Revenue man around this,
they,
there's scientists that want to recreate the,
the men or I've seen that Russian scientists,
they've,
they've got the DNA who tours as a huge field source in,
in,
in a very barren lands.
Yeah.
They're talking about how they could survive like,
and they would just fucking butchered them and cook up this delicious meat.
What do you think?
Oh,
I bet it's like bed bath,
bath or whatever it's called.
Bison,
Bison.
We'll do a totally different type of animal though.
Yeah.
You know,
bisons are related to like horses and shit.
That's like the same.
The hoofed animals.
I mean like to the same,
you know,
they're different,
but they're related.
I don't think elephants in that.
I think that's a totally different thing.
Right?
Yeah.
But that's where they would incubate the,
uh,
the embryo.
So in Africa to people eat a lot of elephant.
Is that you?
They used to,
I know they still hunt them.
Yeah.
It's bad.
People don't understand that.
They kind of have to hunt them in some places.
Some places they overpopulate and they start fucking with the people that live
there and
fucking dead like most,
I mean,
it's,
it's horrible.
There any elephant of male elephants are fantastic animals.
It's horrible than any of them have to get killed.
But if people are going to live there and elephant's going to live here,
you're going to have to choose between elephants and people or you're going to
have to move those elephants and get them somehow.
The fuck out of there.
I'm of the paypal thing,
man.
Elephant ears are delicious.
Apparently the fuck is wrong with you today.
Leathery.
I got hit by an elephant.
Do you still have that elephant?
A horn.
The Ivory Dildo.
Do you still have that?
What?
You don't remember that?
No.
Okay.
You don't remember an ivory deal dude,
that escapes you.
Really?
Wow.
See I'm doing what you do now stu,
but I'm just making shit up.
Oh,
not fun as it.
That's a good for compensation is.
It was actually a possibility though.
I was like have an ivory dildo blackouts.
I've seen like I've met somebody that has like something ivory that's like,
why is that ivory?
That's go ahead and I'm trying to think like,
oh did I did a girl.
They had about it.
The thing about ivory is
there's a ban on ivory,
but they harvested many tusks before the band that it's readily available.
You can buy pre ban ivory,
it's called and you got to look at it this way.
Those animals were already murdered and they were murdered for their hoe there.
Their horns,
you know their tasks and you know you should do something with it.
I mean someone should either have it,
you know and buy it as a decoration because it's beautiful and you know to
remind people that you know these,
these majestic animals,
you know live and they have these crazy horns or use it to make things out of
it.
But otherwise you're just wasting the fact that these things died.
Yeah,
they don't make so bad ivory now but it is good.
So the fuck is wrong with you again
till you are like the perfect child,
the child.
So strange working with you.
It is good self doubt and ivory soap is perfect.
That's all you need,
right?
Use Soap or do you go to the liquid soap?
Because I recently switched back to soap because I saw some study about how
dirty and gross soap is and then I went to body soap instead and then I recently
back to body soap.
I use this stuff called defense soap.
It's all for grappling.
It's soap that's designed with all these natural oils in it,
like tea tree oil and stuff like that.
Eucalyptus oil smells great and it's,
it's probiotic so it encourages healthy bacteria and kills negative bacteria.
Kills everything off,
recording bad off your body,
but it's not antibiotic or antibacterial so it doesn't fuck with a natural
chemistry of your scan.
It actually enhances it and it smells good and it's healthy.
It's really good for your skin and it's great for after Jujitsu cause you know
everybody,
when you do Jujitsu you always worry about getting skin rashes,
whether it's ringworm or some people would get staph infection from scratches
and shit like that to you so it wash cloth.
When?
When you shower with eating soap.
Sometimes I use a couple of different things I gave up on this first punch
things in my hand.
What's the shit like?
The bacteria and all that crap.
Get on that.
He's a freshman and use the same one.
I see.
I don't use anyone I to use my hand.
Thank you.
Clean the sponge off man.
He washed the sponge off and I don't think it's fucking rocket science.
You still might be too much of a pussy.
Don't be worried about bacteria and your sponge.
Should get that fucking soap in there,
you'll be fine.
But yeah,
the defense soap is the shed.
If you want to try it out,
you go to defense soap.com I think.
And they're uh,
it's,
it's like it's the guy who owns the company is a guy whose kids wrestle and you
know,
he's always been around wrestling and you know,
he got tired of all these kids getting ringworm.
So he developed a soap that was a natural soap to combat combat.
Ringworm cause a lot of people to go and get antibacterial soaps and that
antibacterial,
it kills all the good bacteria.
So all the shit,
that's what you need to do is take what?
Probiotics?
Yeah,
when people don't know,
it's one of the most important things to when when cold season comes around,
man ain't hands wash your fucking hands,
but take probiotics.
Take like acidophilus and kids.
Yeah.
And tea is a good one too.
And the reason being is because these are aggressive,
healthy bacteria and when you come in contact with shitty bacteria,
you're aggressive,
healthy bacteria that you're getting from the acid office will actually fight it
off and it keeps your body healthy and strong,
strengthens your immune system,
wash your fucking hands and take that shit and we'll have half the problems.
I didn't have the hand sanitizer thing like crazy nowadays.
Johnny rotten was telling us a great story last night about soap is a fucking
amazing story that there was a massive wait till he gets here.
I think I'm going to be talking about it right now.
We'll have them come back on.
I don't know the full details anyway,
but I can't just tease people like that to him next week when maybe we might
have while we tweet,
tease them with the Guam story.
Anyway,
what happens is we'll go back to that,
don't worry.
And this guy figured out was that there was soap,
um,
in hotel rooms and he would go and he would wash once with it and he would put
it back and he thought,
what happens to that soap?
Do they throw it out?
So he contacted all these major chains of hotels.
It says,
what do you do with your soap?
We know when someone uses it once and just tosses it out.
They go,
well,
we just throw them away.
And he said,
well,
you know that there's like,
you know,
an incredible amount of people die of just diarrhea and children die.
Right?
The world countries because they don't have soap to wash their hands with and
they're just dying of diarrhea.
And this guy decides that he's going to organize this foundation to collect soap
from these hospitals and they clean off the soap and then be redistributed to
all these poor places and they're saving people's lives left to right.
Amazing.
Amazing Shit,
man.
Amazing.
But then without so well,
it just shows you how,
what's really going on is we're fighting off organisms all the time.
It's a constant battle for organisms.
Yeah.
Of it.
Since there's,
you know,
six,
7 billion people on earth now that there'd be some micro that just like in
everything nature,
when population gets out of control,
that has to be something that calls the herd.
Well there is,
we just keep killing them.
We keep finding vaccines for them.
We keep finding ways around it,
but without a doubt that's what they're doing.
And try to like,
like you know,
antibiotic resistant tuberculosis or Murcia Staff.
That's a perfect one because it actually comes from hospitals and I mean people
get in hospitals and it also,
um,
is one of those things where they suspect that a lot of what this stuff comes
from is people taking their antibiotics but not finishing the full cycle.
So when you take like antibiotics and only take it for a couple of days and you
go,
I think I feel okay,
well you haven't killed off all that bacteria.
So the bacteria that lives is stronger because of it.
And then it gets to leave off someone else,
you know?
So are we,
by fighting things off,
we're creating even stronger things and by our own stupidity,
you know,
negligence and using drugs correctly and not just giving a shit.
You know,
you got to take probiotics,
people,
if you learn anything from this show,
it's that n that Ralphie may got arrested in Guam.
So Ralphy did you get strep throat a lot?
I'm
not even answering.
All right.
So,
so meanwhile,
back,
back in Guam,
Marianna's trench hard to his trenched in the world.
Yet you had this bag that you just let them go.
I had a backpack,
right?
And at the bottom of it,
I had 14 grams and a smelly proof bag.
She's just Christ.
14 grams.
That's almost a pound.
No,
14 grams.
It's ounce ounces instead of grams.
And 14 grams is almost announced.
Why do you have no,
no,
it's,
it's half an ounce.
Half an ounce.
14 grams.
15 grams.
So why do you have that much weed?
Um,
I thought I took it all out.
I took out three and a half gram.
I mean three and a half.
What's annoying about grams and shit?
Grams or metric.
Okay,
but 20.4 ounces or not or that's the standard.
That's what we use.
So like we have all this shit mixed up.
Like grams are mixed up.
If you do a joke about grams are drug addicts,
no drugs or cereal lovers.
I always get them fucking confused.
Teddy.
That's weird.
They're from a different system.
Then when we get low,
we use grams.
But like when someone talks to me about centimeters,
I have to go,
okay,
what is that?
What is that 1.34?
I'm always dealing with kilograms two because 2.2 pounds we do fights in Europe.
The weirdest one is in England they have stones.
Stones,
right.
Which is why I believe it's somewhere around 13 pounds stone.
He'll say he's 10 stone.
That means you like 130 pounds.
Wow.
How weird.
Is that?
Crazy.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
They got a lot of leftover shit.
The reason why they drop ins and stuff like that.
What horses?
Uh,
Hans horses with hands,
they measure a horse is high and guitars by bias by its hands mean they call it
hands.
Like oh persons hand.
How many hands on person?
I think it's like 8.4 inches is his one hand.
I don't.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
So like a horse stance,
like 12 hands.
Big fucking horse.
How strange is the whole fucking measuring system being different everywhere.
Inches and kilometers.
We're all supposed to convert millions.
Just said fuck it.
Isn't that weird that we didn't do that?
How dumb are we?
Like we wanted to make sure that people like figured it out.
So we said,
you know what?
It's too complicated.
People,
not enough people are going to figure it out.
Fuck it.
Oh it is is just a new system based on 10 yeah,
give you learn inches.
Fucking for sure you can learn kilometers.
It's all going away very soon.
Going away.
All the difference.
You know things like the,
the,
the grams,
the ounces,
the language barriers,
everything's fucking going away in like five years.
Even maybe 10 years when they get so good that voice activation,
like being able to like have something on your person.
So if a person's talking Japanese,
it's automatically just going to translate for you into English.
If somebody is telling you 12 feet and stay of 12 ounces or whatever,
it's going to cook.
When you translate languages,
like say if you translate Japanese into English,
you're going to have to also,
if you're going to translate it into English and have it direct,
it's going to come out real funky because the way they talk and communicate is
almost alien.
And so there's a lot of creative license involved in structuring sentences that
are going to make sense,
easy compared to the most technology.
You know,
that's,
I mean,
look at the shit already.
I mean you,
you're fucking calling up Macy's and it's like say one,
you know,
say two.
And that's just like generic.
That is pretty dope.
I love the car thing.
I love being able to tell my car,
call Brian,
and it just calls you.
That's insane,
man.
That is so dope.
Yeah,
everybody's,
I volunteer going to do that.
It's amazing that,
that freaks me out.
And um,
my friend Cade has,
I'm not kidding.
It was,
Dustin has,
I'm one of those droid exes and he's sent to fall to shit.
He sent a text by talking to it.
He's like talk to it and he no,
he made something like,
you know I'm here with Joe Rogan and he says I love you.
And I look at it and it says I'm here with Joe Logan.
Those the only one who was wrong,
it picked up Logan instead of Rogan.
Was he like,
hey my battery's about to die on my droid.
Call me.
Call my friends.
Oh nevermind.
I don't know.
But it's fun.
Suck battery life.
They suck battery life.
Yeah,
but you can always keep an extra battery.
And the thing about iPhones,
it's suck cause it was when they die like yours did last night.
Hi that they die and it takes 10 minutes to turn back on because they're sitting
there like a dumb ask on what the fuck.
It's like that last dollar of gas when you prepay,
you're sitting there going,
why is this going so slow?
There's no reason to force me to quit.
They want you to keep,
is that what it is?
Because you ever done that?
I've never done that before.
I've never walked away,
but I want to start doing that.
You want to walk away?
You're like,
you keep your dollar.
My fucking time here.
Holding your handle is worth more than a dollar.
To me that's like toilet bowl technology.
That should be fixed by now.
There should be no extra two minutes of waiting for the last dollar of gas.
When you pre play,
come on.
It's fucking,
they have one of those with the new iPhone.
Remember how they used to be able to buy the old chart?
The the extra large charger.
It was gigantic and it was a not a charger whether battery and it was on the
back of it acted as a case but also acted as a battery and a double.
Did they have that for the new phone?
The new iPhone or the iPhone four but had one of those new big ones from
amazon.com is it a just as cumbersome and large?
It's pretty big.
There's a few different ones now that the new iPhone has like 40% more battery
life.
So does this one have double that a lot faster?
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's the,
the,
the ones that,
I forget the name of that company that makes it,
but they a double your battery life too.
We're Ofi Melfi Mouthy,
I dunno.
Like mouthy May.
Yeah.
Power and battery span.
That is a big major holdup there.
Like these electric cars are trying to put together.
That's all wealthy matters.
But when you're going 150 miles,
that's it.
That's the best you can do is 150 miles.
And that's if you drive cool.
If you don't freak,
like they took one of those Teslas,
you know they have those electric look sports car and they beat the fucking shit
out of this thing around a track.
But it was,
it was cooked in like a couple of miles,
man.
A couple of miles.
That bitch was done.
And how they did it like for maybe 20 miles or something.
And they've even ran this track a few times,
a few laps and then to full space cowboy [inaudible] juice.
It was done.
Yeah.
They tested it against a bunch of other cars like the Boxster and all these
different sports cars are different,
like a little sporty little sort of convertible type cars.
It's not there yet.
And other technologies not quite there yet.
And the wait is ridiculous.
So he got all this weight behind the car.
You know,
there's no real engine in the front.
It's not like a big Fucking v eight that balances out all these batteries in the
back.
Now it's like this weird little electric engine in the front and in the back
you've got this fucking giant bricks and bricks of these lithium ion batteries
and it's super heavy and they're going to die.
They're not going to last.
They're going to die off.
You know,
it's not simple like you just change the spark plugs.
Now you've got to get new batteries,
you've got all new batteries,
your batteries suck now.
[inaudible] it's weird man.
It's like that technology,
that area of technology.
It seems to be,
there's a little bit of a hump there.
Yeah,
it's going to turn into wireless and it has to be,
cause I know.
No Man.
These
fucking thanks for that.
Yeah.
It was Westinghouse and they found out what he was doing.
The closed them down and they shut him the fuck down.
Crazy guy wanted to give away free electricity to the whole will radiate down.
It's fair.
That's probably what's next though for a,
when it says AARP is based on heart,
based on Tesla's technology,
all technologies based on Tesla really is that.
But all modern technology fleshlight technology but directly did,
um,
a test lab,
something to do with it,
I would assume so.
I bet we're to find out a bed.
So,
you know,
it took him like 30 years after his death to finally get the credit for
inventing the radio descended from Tesla's work.
Wow.
Dude.
They,
it took like 30 years after his death to get credited for inventing radio.
Yeah.
Everybody gives it to Marconi.
Still when you hear about it,
you hear Marconi.
Yeah.
You don't hear about a hundred different fucking things.
What Dude?
He was constantly inventing,
but they said he was like a,
um,
like um,
autistic.
He would be diagnosed today.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you know,
I've talked about that with a,
a friend of mine that I have that,
that has autistic children or a autistic kid and he's like the aptitude that
these kids have for learning things and for can co holding information and um,
for dispensing it and spitting it back out like he's like,
it's shocking.
It almost makes you think like,
wonder if this is like some weird hiccup up to the next stage of evolution that
what we're seeing is obviously a disease.
These kids are obviously impaired when it comes to being able to communicate
emotionally and being able to reach out and don't you think nature constantly
when it goes to evolve a,
uh,
in,
in anything,
any form over the history of the,
of,
of the earth through evolution that it's made a lot of fuck ups tell the one
thing hit and then boom,
that's the next level.
Well,
that's the idea is that we have mutations and that from those mutations,
the ones that are useful are kept in a natural selection.
Dicks dictates that we,
we move in that direction now.
But that's what all of the evolution of mankind or any animal supposed to be
from.
That's one of the theories.
You know,
there's a few theories,
but the,
the idea that these kids that are super genius kids,
like what they're having is,
uh,
you know,
just like a blip or just a glimpse as to the potential of what human beings can
do.
There's this one kid,
man,
I don't know what we talked about on the podcast.
I think we might've,
he,
he flew over Europe and looked out his window at Germany from his airplane and
then drew it when he got home.
Drew it in absolute perfect detail.
Every city,
every or every rather block,
every house,
every window,
all in the perfect place.
Perfect perspective,
perfect size.
It's fucking incredible.
And this is Lizzie human being.
This is a human being that can do something that I can't do and you can't do,
but you can't brush your teeth.
He has a hard time with a lot of other aspects of life.
And I'm wondering if like one of this is like some overpowering blip of the new
future.
You know,
this overpowering just like one little thing.
Like maybe he doesn't have the whole package,
he doesn't have the whole super fucking doctor Manhattan package.
That one gets to a thing that the one nun,
that ops spring.
What's that going?
Maybe that's definitely wappinger guide though.
You know,
that's that same thing,
you know like the movie rain man,
whatever that disease is that,
yeah,
it is the same thing.
Autism.
Yeah.
So maybe anyone that's special needs is the future of what we know.
It's not special needs because a lot of that is just a mistake that,
you know,
in the dog eat dog world of nature,
we would not allow to survive.
You know,
if we were living thousands of years ago and you had kids that were like heavily
deformed,
they didn't live,
you know,
that's just what happened and get eaten.
Yeah.
I mean so,
but it's like,
but it all is mutation,
you know,
mutations sometimes.
I mean,
the idea is that it's,
isn't it like the idea that a lot of mutation comes from radiation comes from
like just fucking shit and space and assignment that there's triggers mutation
and sometimes these mutations lead to evolution to better survivability.
Yeah,
man,
it could,
it could very well be that what we're saying.
I mean,
could you imagine if you are a regular person who had,
you know,
regular social skills and totally normal and you regular insecurities,
but for whatever reason you were capable of looking at Berlin out the window of
an airplane and then just drawing it in extreme detail,
like into a point where people are shocked.
Like you've got some imaginary great website of retention,
but that'd be amazing.
I mean,
man,
that's a photographic memory beyond comprehension,
but it's him,
but it's always someone who's fucked up.
It's almost like you only get so much horsepower,
you know,
and your brain has so much horse power.
How much do you want to dedicate to this?
How much is it you going to dedicate to art?
How much you're going to dedicate to think?
Well.
Yeah,
Michelangelo,
Leonardo Davinci.
I wonder what those dudes,
they were supposedly autistic according to,
you know,
cause they are in written history.
You,
I bet their pimp
that Michelangelo and Da Vinci where both autistic.
Why do you think that they say they were higher functioning?
Autistic is what they would be described as the real period.
But how do they know that they don't have any recordings of them communicating
diaries.
They have letters,
they have the communications,
the writings and I had to,
when she's writing expansively found your shit and they just looked at him and
go,
he's retarded.
Made was retarded.
They would be fucking A's.
Retarding saw his comedy and we knew he was a talented performer,
but we always wondered what was it?
Oh well we read his writing.
We realized he was retarded.
People just like judge you and shit based on shit they find hundreds of years
from now that's can't do that.
You can't tell me that Leonardo Da Vinci had autism.
That's what they're going to do.
You know,
if we caught Chaucer,
a genius.
But there was some other guy who was a dirty guy,
you know,
I mean Chaucer's dirtiest thing was the Miller's tale.
Who,
who are you talking about?
Geoffrey Chaucer.
Who's done,
what does this,
the first novelist,
the first novelist ever.
Well,
he didn't write the first novel.
The first novel was bail will,
but uh,
the first,
uh,
novel of substance,
they was printed with the printing press was Geoffrey Chaucer's Canterbury
Tales.
Oh yeah.
And one of them is called the Miller's tale.
And like he uses the past tense of Shit.
And this is in like the 15 hundreds chat.
Yeah.
Powerful.
It was great.
And that
he's given credit with the,
creating the word fuck,
a great word is that,
and writing it down and you're using it.
But I thought that was supposed to be for fornication and the consent of the
king.
That's what it was originally for.
Unlawful carnal knowledge.
One of the two that does a lot of debate about that.
But he used it in print or like,
fuck you.
Like,
yeah,
like go fuck yourself real or let's fuck.
Wow.
Yeah.
Powerful.
And,
but there was somebody else.
I mean,
you think he's the only writer in all of England and then ever wrote a dirty
shit,
you know,
it just never got published,
late like,
like a,
you know,
if we just judge comedy by Seinfeld,
okay,
what we do,
you and I,
but not even considered comedy,
we'd be ranting lunatics,
you know what I mean?
In comparison with the joke set up,
punch,
you know,
no opinion,
observational comedy,
you know what I mean?
It's like what?
He was the most popular and therefore he's known as that times greatest guy.
There is nothing that shows the evolution of culture more than standup comedy,
you know?
In my opinion,
it's real weird when you go back and like listened to like Lenny Bruce and
stuff.
I'll go back and listen to like,
this is stuff that he got him arrested,
you know?
And like,
yeah,
it's less than a potluck at the fucking comedy store.
You can get it on NBC comic standing with all the shit.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
I mean it's like barely offensive.
It's so strange.
But he had some good shit though.
Even back then.
Yeah,
he had some good perspectives on like the Catholic church and stuff like that.
How about on how he had on a bunch of different things.
Finally,
how about my favorite one was he did on a homosexuality being illegal.
Oh yeah.
Let's take this man,
homosexuality is illegal.
So they,
if if you're gay,
they arrest you and what do they do?
They put you in jail with a bunch of guys who want to have sex with you.
Yeah.
It didn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense.
This is a joke that he did in like the 50s and I saw a comic who I know is not a
joke thief,
but he,
he tried to resay it in like the nineties and I had to say,
you know,
that's like a Lenny Bruce joke from like 1950 [inaudible] and he was like,
shit,
of course somebody's already thought that up because that's what,
that's what's shitty about it.
All you know,
is that there's so much that it's come before us all.
That's great though.
That's great.
There's always still things to talk about it.
If it wasn't for them,
we would suck.
You know,
this,
you know,
the people need to slowly learn how to take a joke over the course of 50 or 60
years.
The kind of shit that you could talk or I can talk on stage now.
You couldn't do that back then.
Thank God that they did that because they broke a lot of boundaries,
man.
Richard Pryor got a lot of people used to people saying pussy and motherfucker
and he got people used to that shit.
You know,
Lenny Bruce got people used to questioning things,
questioning the use of words,
questioning,
you know,
all sorts of aspects of our culture.
They got people to take a joke.
They got people to like kind of lighten up and understand this.
Just relax.
Everybody.
So worked up over now you know like um,
like uh,
the use of derogatory slang as far as names go,
you know,
it's,
it's just just all worked up.
Like your,
your outrage is a,
is a learned thing.
And if you didn't learn that the n word was something supposed to be offensive,
it would just be another two syllable word.
And,
and,
and by calling at the end where you just embolden that wired and keep it in our
vernacular that if he used the word like groovy or far out or you know,
why do these words and phrases,
you know,
leave our vernacular and become on cool and groovy is still awesome.
It's still good.
I'm still down with groovy and if I see something I'll say far out right now.
Many people say it far out,
man,
he's far out and it be done using that from now on,
far out back.
It's coming back like the fanny pack and Kenny Mack Common.
He'll bring it back.
The fat.
I don't give a fuck a rock,
a fanny pack.
Every time I travel and people look at me,
look at me like if they thought I was kidding.
I thought you were joking.
If they heard me say it,
love affair.
I mean what am I facts are good too,
but I like a fanny pack,
your fucking wallet and all your changing,
you know your team and your bullshit and just take it off,
put it back on.
It's much faster if not trying to get laid man.
So way to go.
Right.
And you know I took care of that a long time ago.
Hollaback.
It's funny how things come and go and style.
At one point in time I'll let her fanny pack was the fucking rage.
You have a Shit Dad with your dad and your dad have the neon green and pink one
green one and he's still,
I think he's still were breast cancer.
That one.
Hey Mirko Cro,
cop rocks one as do his whole team.
A lot of guys in MMA rock.
Mm.
Don't
fuck around Tim crater rocks.
One
man
put me in a choke.
Did it?
Yeah,
the palms.
That time that we were hanging out at Forrest Griffin dude and he didn't like
hammer down on it.
He just enough to get your attention.
Okay,
late then why don't you go ask him to know.
He just walked up behind me and that was his way of saying I love your comedy.
Really?
Yeah.
No,
not a hello not of what's up and but you don't have to interview him on Friday.
I'm going to confront him with this information.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and you put me in a choke right there and I felt,
I felt like,
yeah,
I could go.
I could go out right now.
I mean,
it was like that.
I've never been knocked down like that.
You don't get choked unconscious.
No.
It's not fun.
Yeah.
That,
that was the first time that I'd ever even come close got,
you know,
I don't get into shit like that.
You know a funny one to tie a tie around your neck while you fucker fuck no,
no.
What's wrong with pussy?
Why is everybody got to augment and accelerate it?
She wants you to fuck her wash is holding your time.
Squeezing the time.
No,
I met her gun and they like that.
That's great.
That sounds awesome to check out.
If she could tie me up.
I was like,
bitch,
are you crazy?
Yeah,
no shit.
Your fucking mind.
Right.
To control him saying he many,
many years,
I had terrible judgment when all I cared about was what if there were hot,
you know,
like you're funny.
She was hot and I can get her.
I'm like,
wow.
You know,
like when I was like 22 I was an idiot and a this one chick that I did,
it was just fucking completely bananas and she wanted to,
she was,
she used to get mad at me and she would get mad.
She would pick up a knife.
I'm not,
I'm not boasting.
She wouldn't do anything with it.
Which you pick up a knife and hold it in her hand when she would get mad.
I'm like,
bitch,
you better put the fucking weapon down
cause this has been wow right now.
Wow.
You're at a different level,
dude.
I think that you attract those types of brides.
You know what I mean?
Like I never met a chick like that would pull a knife on you and shit.
She didn't pull the knife.
She's going to use it.
She would just hold it.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying
as fuck though,
Dude.
Crazy.
Right?
Oh this bitch.
Yeah,
she was crazy.
She just beyond crazy.
That's,
that's what I'm talking about.
And where did they go?
They become mothers and then fucking minivans.
I don't know.
No idea where this one,
this is one.
I would probably like to see your Facebook page.
Find out what the fuck.
I don't remember her name though.
I remember her first name.
[inaudible] last name.
Isn't it crazy to think of all the fucking women you've been with,
like how your life intersected with their life or where they net now is a bunch.
I'd like to go back,
but the thing is you don't because that's what you learned from.
You learn from and they learned from you and you learned from them and they're
not who they were back then and neither of you who you were and you weren't no
goddamn picnic either.
I was no picnic when I was 22 I was fucking crazy.
It was a completely insane when I was 22 when you were like knocking people out
and I'm still fighting.
No,
I would see what knocking people.
I think everyone really getting streets insane when they're 22
know what I'm saying?
Every single fucking insanely
crazy.
Sure.
A lot of people are dumb and crazy and they're just,
they haven't got a handle on themselves yet.
But I was exceptionally fucked up cause I was still fighting.
I was still competing,
I was kickboxing and I was doing taekwondo tournaments.
And at that time I did not know what the fuck I was doing with my life.
And it was all spent on just trying to figure out,
it was all the martial arts competition had been my whole past.
And then I was trying to figure out what the fuck are we going to do with my
future.
And then I started getting into comedy and that's when I met this crazy pitch.
It's a knife,
the knife
Boston with Denis leary being around every corner and,
and hearing about,
you know,
Bill Hicks and that stuff.
Well Dennis leary fan first.
Oh,
we always good,
huge Denis leary fan man.
I came to see Dennis leary wants,
I paid to see dom Arrera and dom missed his flight.
Something happened or they rescheduled or whatever.
So,
and Denis leary was the headliner.
I was like,
Oh,
who's this guy?
Where's Dom Irrera Shit.
I was like bummed out,
but leary went up and just lit that fucking place on fire.
Dude,
he destroyed [inaudible] based.
And I remember thinking,
Whoa,
like who is this?
Kind of saw this guy before.
And I was like,
I don't,
I think I'd maybe gun on stage once.
I was like a total raw open miker paying to see this local show on a date.
And I remember I told all my friends,
I brought a bunch of my,
I brought my roommates,
we went to see Dennis leary at Nick's comedy stop and fucking he,
they were like,
Holy Shit,
this guy killer.
It's awesome.
And then it was like maybe a month or two later Hicks came into town and uh,
everybody was like,
oh,
you gotta see this guy like Paul Barkley who was one of the owners of the comedy
clubs,
real comedy comedy kind of sewer.
Really love,
good comic con.
This guy's got great writing.
He got to see this Kylie's in town.
So I take his advice and I go to see him and I see great writing.
But I've heard these premises before and I've heard the bits before,
I've heard a couple of them and like there was like,
Holy Shit,
this guy's like doing the same stuff that Larry was doing.
Like the same premises about like Gee,
as Jim Fixx dying of a heart attack while he's jogging.
It's like a few of them.
They were like,
I don't remember if that was the specific one.
There was a few of them.
They were like really the same jokes and the same bits.
So I asked the local comics,
I go,
what the fuck is up?
And their response was leary steals,
they're like really leery,
just fucking steals,
he's a thief.
And I was like,
wow.
So He's stealing from this guy.
So this guy was like this,
like the most introspective,
really intelligent like guy who liked,
he really was looking deep in a shit and taken mushrooms and going on pay Odie
trips and trying to find himself.
And then I guess some people would just feeding off of it,
you know?
No,
I know in Houston he let me open for him once at the laugh stop listed.
Yeah.
Cause I've been doing standup.
Kairos is 91 [inaudible] 91 wow.
And that's like,
how was he died in [inaudible] 93 [inaudible] 94 [inaudible] 96 [inaudible] 93
was it nice sex?
I don't know.
Sam died in [inaudible] 92 that made me cry this morning and made me cry pouch.
Darren talks about him in such a way.
I have a connection with a couple of radio guys like that where he talks about
we had Sam over,
we knew it was out of control,
you know,
we knew that he was fucking,
it was crazy.
And he was out of control and we knew he was gonna die,
but he was on the road and we wanted to give him a home cooked meal.
So we brought him home from radio and then we just never going to end.
I have a friend of mine cow in Tampa and that's just like that.
And then that,
the fact that he died at 38 and I'm at my level and my comedy and I'm 38 and
it's fucking,
you know,
it fucks with your head,
Dude.
You know,
you especially,
you know,
you thinking about more challenging.
I think about it more and more sense of my children and that's why,
you know,
I'm losing weight slowly and it's,
it's plateaus unless I exercise.
And if I don't feel well,
I can our exercise,
you know,
I hurt,
physically hurt and um,
and then to compound that,
they want to give me a painkillers.
And if I take the painkillers,
I don't want to move.
You know what I mean?
So it's a weird place.
You know,
I've got physical Elma.
I mean,
I've got physical fucking problems.
I was at a car wreck.
I broke 42 pounds,
64 separate breaks.
I'm fucked up.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
You were in a car accident and you have 42 broken bones.
Yeah.
When was that?
Oh,
16 1988.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I was in the hospital for 48 days and then after that I was in a wheelchair for
10 months.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
that's bond.
The swelling I had,
um,
I broke my two vertebrae in my neck.
I cracked or fractured two vertebrae in my neck to three in my back.
I broke one of the wings off my vertebrate,
Eh,
that's all right there.
So I have psychiatric problems.
All right.
And that they say I have amazingly dense bones and that,
uh,
I was very fortunate to live through it and um,
you know,
it just fucking changes everything.
And then it goes,
you're fucking last couple of years of being a teenager then,
then you know,
as a,
people think you're retarded and you get for me.
They thought I was retarded.
And then they gave me a test and found out I was actually really smart.
And then they put me in this beginning scholars program at the University of
Arkansas and that's when I started doing comedy because my group met at a
Shakey's pizza on highway 71 in Fayetteville,
Arkansas.
And,
um,
uh,
my study group,
and again,
a chemistry met there and I fucking hung out.
And there was an open Mike contest and the winner got free pizza and a fucking
picture.
And I had a joke about Vanna white's the dumbest person ever on television.
She doesn't even have to hell no how to spell the words.
They light them up before and she just walks over there and turns the fucking
letter.
I mean,
somebody could tell her how to do it.
why were you shocked when the fucking letter comes up?
You know,
you don't even know how to spell it.
You're the dumbest bitch ever.
Okay.
And then I said,
um,
that I can't,
even though I love def leopard,
I can't see them.
I can't watch them because if I watch them,
uh,
you know,
in concert I feel like I'm mocking the drummer with two arms and clapping and
applauding and raising little hands up.
You know,
I feel like it was what,
how you wouldn't,
you're just started out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And,
and this is just,
you know,
general premise.
I had jokes within and I had seen it enough that I had this and I want to stand
up comedy contest and it went on from there.
I moved from the Shakey's pizza to the Ramada Inn out by the mall in
Fayetteville.
What?
I was going to school and it all happened because I got,
they tested me and I got into comedy,
you know,
they test to do and they tested me.
See if I was retarded,
the game and Iq tests and they found out I was actually born to be going into
comedy because I said you needed to go and tell jokes.
No,
no.
Is that fact that my study group showed up there at the,
at the Shakey's pizza where they had the dream of being a comic before that?
Or is it just did.
I had had,
but I never,
you know,
I mean,
I lived in Arkansas,
you know,
I went to school in Winslow,
Arkansas.
Okay.
Any comics from Arkansas?
There's a couple,
there's a couple Arkansas to crazy town.
Huh?
It's a crazy place.
Yeah.
It's a crazy state of state of mind.
He's shit there,
man.
That was a lot of things.
One what Bill Clinton became president there.
Like he was a governor of Arkansas.
I know,
right?
Yeah,
man,
it's,
it's a,
it's the biggest city.
Little Rock.
Yeah.
But now actually probably a,
they've consolidated them into threes,
the three cities into one mega.
Megalopolis I go down there and do you work there?
I do concerts in little rock.
I want to,
I want to do one of the University of markets.
I'm a big razorback fan and um,
I love to do one back there because my first Gig I got to work with Sam
Kennison.
I want to,
when it was talent show contest is k hog.
The local radio station had a talent show contest.
He was playing the ballroom and I'm like 89.
No,
it makes me sad about comedy dude.
When I remember Houston.
Remember what Houston was like?
Yeah.
I want to remember what it was like when I first started going there.
When that fucking had open mic that would stop and they would start at seven and
go toe to toe and then never,
it never comedian repeated or if they did it was a sketch or something live and
the audience constantly came in and out and you're walking outside and smoking
weed and bag in the back of the room and talking shit.
And there was this comics there,
there was a lot of good crying,
there was a lot of experimental,
amazing,
smart should ethic of the town.
There was like one hacks in there and they all knew that.
Like Hicks came from there and Kennison came from this and heritage.
Yeah,
there was something there and that talented boy,
it just got extinguished.
It just got extinguished,
you know.
And I hear guys say,
Hey,
we're working out again.
We've got this going on again.
But man,
there's like that.
You don't hear about God's coming out of Houston anymore.
No,
not every coach to him out of there.
And there was a bunch of man,
that's my favorite line in hers,
Iti.
Remember Brian Herzing I genius dude is funny as fuck.
And it just kind of like stopped drunk that quit comedy.
That ain't cool man.
It's weird.
It's like that place like how to a flower that was growing and then somewhere in
other clouds grow overhead and the flower fucking died right there.
Man.
I think comedy,
he was about to evolve from there.
There was wanting to set up is a bunch of places,
30 40 comedians come out of there and,
and,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm only giving you like maybe 10 15% of the actual comedy community.
I mean there was one at open Mike that had literally over a hundred comics
before.
Okay.
And that not everybody got to go on it.
So the Improv there,
it's not doing it now.
They eight level and they don't,
they don't foster local talent and they don't have to clean man.
The last stop was dirty.
It was dirty and Marty paths running it.
It was just fun.
We're still place was chaos.
There was nuttiness to the extreme.
That's what you need.
The only way you get the real comedy to develop,
to do,
especially developing competence,
there has to be chaos.
It has to be like the comedy store.
It has to be like,
like that place they get stifled.
If it doesn't,
like I didn't grow as a comedian.
I mean I grew to a certain level,
like I knew how to rock a room,
but I had to do it cleaner and I had,
and I was a product of my environment.
I,
I went up,
um,
a lot of times it,
me work in the last stop was maybe five,
six times a year,
you know,
as work goes.
But I would work out every weekend at this place called the comedy showcase and,
and um,
go freeway and few coy.
And it was owned by a very smooth,
I think you smoother than,
um,
it's probably one of the most smooth comedians I've ever seen as far as like an
hour ago in and out of subject.
Like it's just one conversation.
A guy named Danny Martinez and his club,
uh,
he taught comics,
like he would have a Wednesday through Sunday and you get 10,
15 minute spot.
And it was just a showcase club.
And then also I'd go and play the,
uh,
the,
the big black,
I mean the,
um,
uh,
the hip hop comedy stop up in a hotel black room.
And that's where I developed all these black Joel's cause that was the fucking
audience.
I mean that's all I had,
you know,
and,
um,
and then I started meeting,
you know,
I was surprised to have hanging around with Mexicans and black people.
All right.
And people go,
where did you get this fucking axe him from?
And where are you?
Why you talk like that?
And it's like,
well it was funny to the fucking crowd.
I was,
I was trying,
I was playing for what you're saying is there was a lot of different places to
go up there and he's so used to how to real interest in comedy dynamics when
that laugh stop closed down.
There really wasn't much there anymore.
It was even close.
Second Laugh stop.
But the second was not the same.
No,
no.
And before it even close,
it wasn't the same because when Babbitt left,
right.
And then,
uh,
homeboy,
Pete,
Pete came in,
he was a good guy.
Nice Guy,
Pete.
But Pete was like,
he was like,
oh,
straight up accountant sort of book writing sort of a guy.
And you need tradie Weirdos running comedy clubs.
Yeah,
yeah.
You need any guys like,
like our friend in San Francisco,
you know you need,
and there's a guy in Seattle that,
that a couple of guys in Seattle that and our permission and I never come to
showcase in Ann Arbor.
No,
dude,
we had a good fucking time,
man.
I was there with Thompson girl.
Fucking great.
Hire that guy.
Straight.
A funny man.
A lot of people say he's really funny.
I don't even know that guy,
man.
I'm also going to follow them on Twitter.
Go see that guy in concert or wherever he's touring and he comes at me
someplaces he's fucking hilarious.
He's really,
really good.
He's really funny man.
It's a great guy to really,
everybody says he's phenomenal.
He's phenomenal.
And uh,
I got to Piss.
So I think this is a perfect time to end this podcast.
Great.
Shazamm southerners.
Nice guys.
Uh,
thank you very much for 200 and thank you fleshlight for sponsoring it.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
you can get 50% off the fleshlight.
Um,
there's a code name Rogan.
You have to type it in the,
uh,
New Year's eve show.
We still don't have the ticket link as soon as I have it will go up.
Thank you very much for all the interest.
I keep getting a Twitter messages about it,
so it'll be me and Joey Diaz at the Mandalay Bay theater going to be the shit.
It's like 1700 people.
It's going to be a lot of it going to be such a grid time man.
If you want to no drama in Vegas and Vegas Ed for good new years is nothing but
fucking drama.
I you won't be able to leave your fucking hotel after a certain time to cut the
strip down and it's a forever fucking walk.
The smartest thing to do is have tickets.
All lay people would take it to a bail out to the fucking,
uh,
the barricades to get into the masses.
All right,
get you tickets.
I rarely buy him.
Go see a great show.
I highly recommend Joey.
Coco Diaz is possibly the funniest person I've ever been around and my life.
It makes me laugh more than anybody else ever.
And uh,
I,
the two of you together is just a fucking dynamic.
She's a real freak.
He's afraid.
Not a whole lot of real freaks out there is a lot of people fronting.
Pretend it'd be free walking around with a few hills,
different colors.
One converse all star that's red and one that's my ass curb.
I'm silly.
I go to hot topic.
I'm bad ass anyway.
That's it.
Thank you.
Ralphie May.
Ralphie may we gotta get you on Twitter.
You have an account.
Don't you have a couple of years?
That shit son.
I know the Twitter people are tweeting right now.
Yes.
Ralphie use it.
Ralphy okay.
I can get on at Jesus Christ.
Thank you everybody.
And a next week we've got cliffy be on Wednesday and a,
we're gonna work on getting Brian pro scene.
See if we can hook him up next week to,
and if not,
we're going to do a Joey Diaz one to soon.
Another one in the house.
Bitches.
Thank you very much,
Ralph from me for coming on.
I appreciate it,
my brother.
Always good to see you.
Thank you,
sir.
Red Band.
Go to red ban at Twitter.
Red Ban.
He needs more followers.
Is Very,
very insecure about his Twitter account.
Yes.
It makes him sad.
Some,
some chick.
A fucking bar bag.
Please date him.
Black Girl Sam.
Yes.
That's the next level.
Black chicks.
That next level shit.
Thank you everybody.
So next week you love you bitches.
Boy.